e
the house will come to
water the chair recognizes a member from
roburn representative Osburn who moves
at the house ad Jour from the session to
May 23rd 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos n eyes have in the houses
adjourned house will attend a Prayer by
house chap Reverend Bob Stewart
Pastor St uh Paul's United Methodist
Manchester good morning Mr
Speaker good morning New Hampshire House
of
Representatives morning let us be in an
prayer good morning
God we give you thanks for this brand
new
day we come together this morning as the
legislative house for this great state
of New
Hampshire there will be many legislative
house bills that will be presented
before us
today and we ask oh God that you guide
and direct us this this
day help us to discern the very nature
of all the legislation
presented may we read with open eyes may
we listen with open
ears and may we discern with Open
Hearts help us to be respectful to all
those that will speak before this body
today help us to be respectful of each
other even when we do not
agree oh Spirit of the Living God may we
reflect your image and love to all that
see and hear us on this
day we continue to plant the seeds of
Hope together for this great state of
New
Hampshire and oh gracious and loving God
I once again ask for your grace and
blessing upon each leader and
represented representative that is
gathered here this morning bless their
leadership and bless the decisions that
they will make
today oh god of us all again we give you
thanks for this day and for the many
blessings and joys you have placed in
our
lives we pray that this will be a
fruitful day and that we represent and
honor you and our constituents to the
best of our ability
peace it is in our love for you oh God
amen the chair recogniz the member of
Manchester representative David priest
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the rep stands
one nation God indivisible withy and
all the chair now recognizes Katie
Hickman of Manchester who will now sing
anthem can you
see by the D
early
light what so
proudly
[Music]
we at the
Twilights last
gleaming whose
brri and bright
stars through the
per
fight or the r
we
watch were so
gely
[Music]
streaming and The
Rock
buring in
air gave
Pro the
night that our
oh
[Music]
that
wave the
land of the
free and the home of the
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to request for Le
of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives D Simone frus O'Brien
Spain and trevan the day important
business Representatives O'Hara Maria
Perez Sanborn Marjorie Smith Summers
Woodcock the day illness in the family
representative Crawford the day death in
Reed these leads of rtion shall be gr
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Melody
hok and Amelia Caravan students from
[Applause]
day Mr Speaker please welcome Lila
Porter love guest of Representative
Manos Tracy cogsdale guest of
Representative Ellen Reed Dale Swanson
guest of Representative elberger Michael
vasaro guest of Representative petrigno
Nicholas McCree guest of Representative
hackin Phillips Sam opal guest of
Representative Morse Tanya Frost guest
of Representative priest George and Lois
deer guest of Representative rung they
are with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
[Music]
house the house will attend to Senate
messages
Mr Speaker the Senate URS of the house
in the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendments in the passage of
which amendments the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
185 relative to the determination of
parental rights and responsibilities
based on shared parenting and requiring
all municipalities and school governing
bodies to post on their official website
the amount of funds received by the
representative Pearson's moved we Concur
Raymond thank you Mr
Speaker good morning currently the
statute requires that judges in custody
cases consider the best interest of the
child when deciding parenting plans this
bill would change that language to
requiring the court to use approximately
equal parenting time this change in
language removes the focus on child's
needs and creates a one siiz fits-all
solution that actually fits very few fam
situations currently 85% of families are
able to come to agreement without the
judge having to make an order that they
have to comply with only about 15% of
high conflict divorce cases uh involve
parents who cannot get on the same page
and create a parenting plan on their
own this new language ignores the child
in the conversation about parenting
plans it ignores children's activities
and schedules for example children who
play sports children who are in count
um scouting children who have part-time
jobs because remember from the age of
three or four until 18 which is the
majority of childhood our kids are doing
things and when you don't look at what
the child is doing and you only look at
the parents and say half and half you're
ignoring what's best for those
kids this language also ignores the
realities of the complex family living
situations that we have today for
example how does one achieve
approximately equal parenting time when
parents live in two different school
districts again for 12 years most kids
are in school how do families manage
that how do they manage when they live
far apart and they need to arrange two
different daycare providers for their
time this language treats children as
marital property to be div divided up
when marriages fail that's not good for
kids we should not be making divorce
harder on children we should be allowing
our courts to put the focus on what's
best for kids when they are going
through these difficult family events so
I agree that the current language is not
perfect however it works for the vast
majority of families and this language
will hurt all families going through
divorce so I ask everyone to non-c
Concur and I ask for a division
Pearson in my opinion it was not a bad
Bill to start with but the Senate added
the phrase the best interests of the
child and to me that's an important
Improvement
and my hearing not being what it is if a
division wasn't called for I would like
one representative Mark Pearson asked
for a
division members take your seats this
[Music]
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill
185 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative long for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I believe that
language does not add up to actions and
if I know and believe that
primarily all these decisions should be
on the best interest of the child then
would I press the red button thank
you chair recognize representative Mark
inquiry if I know the Senate added the
phrase the best interest of the child
button the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 185 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button your oppos you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
vote 191 voting yay to concur 171 voting
adopted chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
en titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
106 relative to creating a family access
plans
recogn representative Mark Pearson moves
speak thank you Mr Speaker this bill
passed out children and family law
committee on February 6th with a vote of
14 to zero it was passed by this house
on March 7th with a Voice vote the
Senate adds the words
substantial and material to one sentence
here are the two versions our version
read upon finding by the court pursuant
to a motion for Family Access order or a
motion for contempt that its order for
parenting time has not been complied
with their version reads parenting time
has been substantially and materially
violated I'm a co-sponsor of this bill I
believe the Senate version makes it
clear the court will not take action if
somebody is once in violation in a very
minor way that was a concern of some
folks the Senate addressed that that it
would have to be substantial and
material violations I comfortable with
that I ask that we concur with the
Senate the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 10006 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
passes chair recogniz clerk for a f sen
a message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
the concurrence of the house house bill
1189 relative to criteria for reporting
agencies representative Mark Pierce's
moves we concur chair recognizes
representative
long thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the con her motion um the
department the uh division of uh child
support uh warned us that this would be
opposed to Federal
requirements um and it would be an
additional Financial appropriation in
order to change the system I ask that
you uh non-c concur with this thank you
J recogniz representer Mark
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker this uh
bill came about because there was some
sloppiness that we wanted to get fixed
the Senate looked it over and changed
one
word our version said shall not report
as delinquent any aage that does not
meet the federal threshold they added
the word applicable I don't know why
they did that we wouldn't want anything
that's
unapplicable in my opinion but they
wanted that word and that simply says
they want to make sure it meets
applicable federal thresholds okay I
vote I ask that we vote to
concur the motion before us is the Cur
on House Bill
1189 are you ready for the question
division a division has been requested
the motion before the current House Bill
1189 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
your oppos you press the red button
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote El will tend to stay
vote 181 voting aay 188 voting aay the
motion
fails
motion uh Mr Speaker I'll move to uh
non-c concur
the motion before us is to non-c concur
1189 division has has been requested
seats the motion before us is the non-c
concurent house bill 1189 if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
your opposal press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 185 voting aay 183 voting aay the
passes chair recog Isa clerk for a f
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs of the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage amendment
of Senate as URS the house house bill
1588 relative to court jurisdiction over
education representative Mark Pearson
Wier move that we concur chair
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker this bill
relative to court jurisdiction over
persons receiving special educ
came out of Children and Family Law
committee with the unanimous bipartisan
120 vote it came out of Finance with the
unanimous bipartisan 25 to zero vote it
passed the house on April 11th on a
Voice vote the Senate added an amendment
to appropriate the sum of $3 million
from the educational trust fund for the
purposes of this act the chairman of
Finance reminded me this is not new
money
this is money already there waiting to
be
allocated and if we're going to ask
people to do things we have to have some
money
allocated since the language asking for
something to be accomplished means
little without that money and since the
money in question is money we've already
voted
concur the motion before us is ur on M
Bill 1588 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iose
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as a concurrence to
the house house bill 279 increasing the
penalty for on premises licenses
H representative hunt moves that we
representative hunt and Roy move that we
concur chair recogniz the representative
hunt thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker
the Senate Amendment did remove a minum
offense for if it's a second offense and
U the so it was really more of a
criminal issue so I did discuss with
representative Roy and he was okay with
it and I talked to the uh sponsor of the
bill and she was okay with it so um I
urge you to support the motion to
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 279 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
iose
chair recogniz the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs at the house and the passage of
the Fong entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as concurrence of the house house
bill
645 relative to the establishment of
decentralized autonomous organizations
state representative hunt moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak uh
thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker the
Senate Amendment uh was some things that
the Attorney General requested to have
put into the bill um and the sponsor was
okay with it all the interested entities
were okay with it and I'm very excited
that we're going to get to pass this and
we'll be one of the first states to have
it the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill one 645 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
motion is
adopted jerck and Isaac clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
ask the concurrence of the house house
bill 1018 relative to on premise and
off- premise liquor licenses and
represented hunt moves that we
Murray thank you Mr Speaker and hello
colleagues um this bill like so many
others has expanded Beyond its original
intent and now includes language from s
sp504 which is a bill on a completely
different topic as I'm sure many of you
know in New Hampshire unless private
property is posted with no trespassing
signs folks in New sure are welcome to
do recreational activity on that
property this includes skiing hiking
snowshoeing Etc Property Owners receive
a tax break for leaving their property
open to the public the language that has
been inserted into this bill seeks to
allow Property Owners to post no
trespassing except for a specific list
of recreational activities and then
still receive the tax credit when the
bill was introduced in our committee
originally the prime sponsor explained
that the intention was to allow law
enforcement officials to go onto these
properties and arrest individuals for
trespassing as a way to address
theoretical border crossings in Northern
New Hampshire I asked in committee how
law enforcement would tell the
difference between someone backpacking
or hiking and someone who is supposedly
trespassing on these public lands there
was no answer to that question we also
asked what kind of impact this bill
would have on actually stopping illegal
border crossings and the sponsor
admitted that it would be very minimal
in my eyes it is very clear that this
bill would inevitably lead to the
unnecessary stops of black and brown
people who participate in these
recreational activities as it is many
members of my Latino Community are
detained and forced to show proof of
citizenship when simply traveling up
north these racially motivated
detainments are unconstitutional
dangerous and discourage granted Staters
from participating in everything our
state has to offer the freedoms that we
all have a right to I would urge you all
to vote against this motion so a better
motion can be made thank you
hunt uh thank you Mr Speaker uh the
underlying bill is a pretty important
bill to the Commerce Committee it has a
bunch of series of issues um that we
were working on including uh addressing
the uh issue of
hookas um so when I I got this uh
amendment I called up the chair uh
criminal justice and and asked him I
said what's what happened what's the
story with this issue and he said um
that the committee overwhelmingly
supported it nobody called me and told
me there was a problem with this bill
this amendment I had not heard anything
and believe me I was making a lot of
phone calls to let everybody know that I
would want to hear if there's anything I
should know and I did not hear anything
so this is all a surprise to me and I
would hope you to uh support this motion
so we can actually get these uh this
important liquor bill passed thank
you representative H requested a
division members take your seats this
C
the motion before us to concur on House
Bill
1018 this a division vote chair
recognize representer burrows for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the underlying Bill 1018 was
overwhelmingly passed by both bodies and
if I know that the bill attached by the
body over the wall is a dangerous one
that makes assumptions about trespassers
on our land and if I know that the
attached bill would make it nearly
impossible for law enforcement to
distinguish between a hiker such as
myself who often walks in the woods and
an undocumented migrant creating a
danger to Public Safety would I then
non-c Concur and would I then vote to
non-c
concur chair recognize representative
hunt for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker would I like to
uphold the house position on both pieces
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1018
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
[Music]
represent
Murphy all members present had an
opportunity to vote how for attendance
vote 179 voting a 190 voting a the
motion
fails move to make a motion see your
motion thank you I'd like to move non-c
conference I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
just want non-c concur on this I'm
sorry okay the motion is to nonon I
division uh representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
clear
the motion before us is a nonon Cur on
House Bill 1018 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative hunt for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I am very much in support of the
underlying house bill will I now vote
down this motion so that we can have a
committee of conference and take out
evidently the piece that you don't like
never told me but if you don't like it I
certainly will put it we go to the
committee of conference to defending
that position that we don't want that
extra amendment in there so please vote
no chair recogniz from sen burls for
parliamentary
Ting thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
the underlying bill is a good bill but
that I know that the attached Bill
creates a danger to people who are
simply walking in the woods would I now
vote Yes on a motion to non-c
concur motion before this is non-c
concur when House Bill 101 eight this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 180 voting aay 190 voting aay
motion
fails
rep representative hunts moves
committee uh non-c Concur and go to
1018 and is recognized to speaker please
vote
Yes let me stall so I can get some me I
pen the motion before us is
non-concurrent commit request the
committee of conference and House Bill
1018 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I
those May the eyes have it the committee
passed the chair appoints the following
members representative hunt
representative Ammon representative
buros
representative
oh
B that certainly doesn't look like bolo
to
me chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the F entitled bill with Amendment
the pass of which amendment the Senate
ask occur to the house house bill
1129 relative to the authority to vote
Association represent hun hunt moves
that we concur when is recognized to
speak uh the Senate rephrased one
sentence it didn't change anything but
it was better written so vote
Yes the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1 129 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
passes chair recog Isa the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill
1144 relative to requirements for sewage
Disposal system information to be
disclosed during real estate trans
transactions
H representative hunt moves that we
Concur and is recognized to
speak so we had a couple of uh sewage
bills this year and uh these are going
to be in the real estate uh contract
purchase sale agreement and clarifies uh
what needs to be
disclosed and we like this
changed the motion before us is to ur on
House Bill 11 144 are you ready for the
question all those fav ever say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion
passes chair recan Isaac clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS with the house in the passage
of the following en titled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate Asic occurrence of the house
house bill
1236 establishing a pilot Recruitment
and Retention program within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and relative to the income eligibility
for in andout medical assistance under
representative hunt moves we Concur and
it's recognized to speak uh thank you Mr
Speaker um so I talked to a lot of
people about this one and health and
human services and uh everybody seemed
to be okay with this amendment so I urge
you to vote
Yes the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1236 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
suppose
n okay there has I was informed that
there has been a request for a division
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1236 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button you're oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members presentent had an
opportunity to vote how attendant say
the
vote 175 voting a 194 voting a motion to
concur
fa what reason memorized I'd like to
move um non-concurrent request to
conference Senate Weber moves that we
non Concur and request the committee of
conference are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iose
nay you eyes have it and the motion to
non-concurrent question committee
know I'm
the chair appoints representative hunt
representative Ammon representative
buros and representative bolo on behalf
house chair recognizes the clerk for
message Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to
concur with the house in the amendments
to the following entitled Bills sent up
from the house senate bills 112 134 306
349 413 419 431 447 459 485 Senate Bill
510 chair recognized clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1320 relative to real
disclosure representative hunt moves we
Concur and is recognized to
speak so this is a companion of the uh
wet uh Wetland issue and urge you to
the motion before us is to ur on House
Bill 1320 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
passes
chair chair recogniz the clerk for
recognizes Senator Phillips for make a
motion thank you Mr Speaker to make a
motion State your motion I'd like to
make a motion to reconsider um having
voted on the prevailing side of HB
House Bill 1189 is relative to the
criteria for reporting child support
delinquencies to federal agencies the
motion to concur failed and the motion
to of non-c concur pass 185 to
183 chair recognizes representative
Phillips for to speak to her motion I
simply made a mistake I wasn't paying
attention I'll be honest and I voted to
nonc concur when I should have voted
you the motion before us is to
reconsider House Bill 11
189 a division has been requested
clear the motion before us is to
reconsider House Bill
1189 this is a Divi this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
vote 180 voting yay 188 voting nay the
motion
fails jerck and clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the second
occurs in the passage of with the house
and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate as a
concurrence of the house house bill 1559
repealing the chapter relative to cash
dispensing machines and relative to
disability pensions for Public Safety
violence represent hunt moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak uh
thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker I did
check in with the the chairman of Edna
and she said this language was exactly
what they passed so that they were okay
concur the motion before us is to Cur on
House Bill
1559 FN are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I close n i
have it motion
passes for what reason is a member rise
to make a motion State your motion I
would like to having voted on the
prevailing side I would like to make a
motion to reconsider House Bill 185 and
Yes the bill 185 is relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting and requiring all
municipalities and school governing
bodies to post on their official s it
the amount of funds received by the
state either by allocation or Grant the
171 motion before us is to reconsider on
House Bill
185 roll call uh roll call has been
requested is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill 185 this is going to be a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
representative
Harvey all members present and
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
the
vote 178 voting yay 191 voting nay the
motion
faves chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of
the house and the passage of the
following tital bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concur to the house house
bill 1633 FNA relative to the
legalization and regulation of cannabis
therefore represent of hunt moves that
we
concur the chair recognizes
Sullivan hello fellow members
and oh boy lot people going
Speaker I'm speaking here today in
opposition to the concur motion to pass
as amended by the
Senate HB 1633 is something that
everybody in this body should be proud
of it's something that people on both
sides of the aisle many stakeholders
worked together to come up with
compromise and acted in good faith I
myself worked with my friend from Derry
multiple times had multiple lunches
talking about different concerns as we
worked through this bill throughout this
process this is an great example that
this body can be proud of of passing a
strong bipartisan bill
that was done in good faith to solve
problems that the majority of the people
in this state want solved that's the
type of government that we were hired
and sent here to do
unfortunately the members on the other
body decided to gut all of that good
work and replace it with what is
objectively a deeply flawed profoundly
bad bill when it comes to the goal of
legalizing cannabis sales in New
Hampshire the benefits of
legalization are
many we hear people talk about Revenue
increases we hear about um allowing
people more freedom civil liberties but
the most important one for me standing
here today is to stop arresting people
for things that by and large the
majority in society no longer view as
something particularly serious that need
to ruin people's lives through through
arresting while this does theoretically
do that it doesn't do it until
2026 which is kind of saying that we
would sign a bill that then it doesn't
do the most important part of it for
over a year we could come back next year
and pass a bill that could do it six
months earlier than if we pass this bill
today second if you're concerned about
civil liberties are you really
comfortable with the idea of growing the
The Liquor Commission into a new police
organization that can come into your
home because home grow is not allowed
and supervise what you're doing there
and actually bust people who potentially
have a few homeg grow plants going on
and and it also criminalizes behavior
that is currently legal in New Hampshire
yes let me say that again for those of
you who didn't hear it the first time
there are behaviors in this state right
now that are currently legal for example
if you have a medical card and you
consume a gummy and you are riding in a
car that is acceptable that will become
illegal under this new bill if it
becomes law this should concern
everybody who concerns about who is
concerned about civil liberties as I am
we can do better than
this
second the second big thing is is is
revenue in in scope this I just talked
about legalization but this is a 36 page
bill of which only a few lines talk
about legalization the rest of the
language goes to the structure of how
we're going to sell marijuana and that
structure is really bad like really bad
honestly it doesn't consider small
businesses it doesn't consider the
businesses that are already operating
under the medical system that we
currently have it will give a franchise
model run by the state which despite
what supporters say does put the state
at risk because it is still illegal
federally so if this if we have a
different administration at the federal
level that wants to crack down on
marijuana sales New Hampshire as a state
will be at some level potentially liable
being being the franchise or renting it
out to franchisees also puts a state at
risk because think about it if you go in
with McDonald's and something happens to
you you don't just Sue that that
franchisee you you sue McDonald's as
well New Hampshire is the McDonald's in
this scenario they're not just the
risk I personally have I've been up here
and spoken every time I've come up here
I've spoken on bills that are generally
pro- free market pro- free enterprise
this build does the opposite this
expands government it take allows
government to take full entire control
of an entire new industry taking away
the ability of free enterprise to allow
for innovation in a new industry
Innovation is going to be key because we
don't know what this is going to look
like in 20 years from now what I do know
is that if the if the government is the
one calling the shots and running it
they're not going to be the ones at the
Forefront of innovation because when is
the government the one at the Forefront
of innovation like I think the majority
of in here can agree I urge everybody in
this body who's concerned about this
bill and who really does in good faith
want to legalize cannabis consumption
and sales in the state to vote non-c
concur to vote against this motion to
concur because we can do better and we
should do better and the idea that this
we can somehow fix this deeply deeply
flawed Bill suggest that we acknowledge
it's deeply deeply flawed and we can
somehow fix it next year despite
whatever whoever is serving in the
corner office or serving on the other
side of this wall if you can't pass a
good bill next year we probably are not
going to be able to pass improvements to
this deeply flawed bill please join me
in voting against this motion to concur
thank
verville thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues so I don't think it's any
Secret in this room
I am staunchly in
decriminalization and I've held that
position since a teenager so in 40 some
odd years that position has not wavered
for
me but this is not the New Hampshire
solution this bill is not what we're
looking
for and what I hear from proponents
is this drummed up sense of
urgency that we have to do something we
have to do something now if we don't do
something now then who knows when we're
something who knows who knows when we
won't be able to do
something I do not subscribe to the
premise that something is better than
nothing we have to do something doing
something is better than doing nothing
not in this casee not in this case in
this case doing something is worse than
the status quo and that's why I'm going
to vote against the motion of
concurrence on this on this
bill as the previous speaker said this
government and and stop me if you've
stop me if you've heard this one before
Mr
Speaker pass it
today and we'll fix it
later I never hear
anything thank you Mr
Speaker I've served in this body for
eight
years eight
years how many things did we come back
and fix later in the course of my 8
years of
service and I asked I asked colleagues
this morning you know we're Milling
around Chi chatting fix it
later and nobody could give me an
example of something that we fixed later
so fix later is is for me as a
non-starter it will not be fixed later
this this sort of mirrors our Spirits
laws our liquor laws our liquor laws
were passed shortly after the repeal of
prohibition and they've basically uh
remained more abound since then so what
100 years give or take and so if we pass
this today you're looking at at a 100
years of this being
law I'm not looking forward to
that if I'm lucky enough to get
reelected I'm going to come in with a
slew of um peac meal repeal bills that I
don't think most of you want to spend
time listening to the opponents as to
why these are bad ideas to try and fix
it even though it won't get won't get
fixed this bill is big pot the only
Communications that I got in favor of
this bill was from by was from big pot
big pot loves this bill and if I was big
pot I would love this bill too but I'm
not big pot I'm little
pot and little pot is Mom and Pops and
there's no Mom and Pops in this this is
not free market this is Government
monopoly the government has been telling
me if you do that and I catch you I will
prosecute you I will find you and I will
try to throw you in
jail and now all of a sudden the state
wants to be the pot
dealer for almost eight years from
another section of this building we've
heard how legalized cannabis is not
right for New Hampshire it is not right
for New Hampshire children it is not
right for New Hampshire families it is
not right for New Hampshire well I
disagree with that except for the part
for the children all of a sudden there's
a there's a change of heart over there
in the in the corner of the
building that doesn't move me that
doesn't make this better it doesn't give
me a sense of urgency so I ask you uh
again to to to vote no there's no
homegrown in
this you want to you want to hear the
worst part right is I know I know the
vast majority of my constituents want
legal cannabis and they want it in New
Hampshire and they want it sooner than
later but this is not the right solution
for us for that reason I'm asking you to
press the red button on
concurrence so that a motion of non-c
concurrence can be made so that we can
just dispose of this nonsense and move
on with the business of to of today and
try again next year thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr
Speaker this bill accomplishes my major
goals for cus
legalization I share many of the
concerns others have voiced about the
market it
creates however the system it creates
will either work and be better than
driving to any of our neighbors or I
have confidence there will be the
political will to fix it in the fut in a
future term but legalization will never
be repealed once
pasted please please join me in pressing
the green button and make New Hampshire
the 25th state to legalize weed and
change the national discussion thank you
Howard thank you Mr Speaker and
honorable
Representatives uh today I'm speaking
against concurrence of HB
1633 and if you know me that's kind of a
surprise because I'm a big supporter of
cannabis legalization and I myself am
also a medical patient in fact this
cycle I submitted five Pro cannabis
bills however the bill in front of us
today
is regarding cannabis legalization is
extremely flawed and it's not what's
best for the people of New Hampshire
because it throws medical patients
alternative treatment centers and
recreational users under the bus instead
of building on the success of our
state's successful therapeutic cannabis
program this bill would
completely separate the two systems uh
that would put our current system in
serious Jeopardy in addition potential
harming uh the to the potential harming
of patients ability to access adequate
care this bill also creates two new
Criminal penalties one for second
offense public smoking or vaping and one
for consuming in Motor Vehicles even if
you're a
passenger we know that cannabis laws
have been dis proportionately enforced
against marginalized communities so we
ought to recognize that these new
Criminal penalties would be
disproportionately enforced as
well but let's focus for a moment on the
alternative treatment centers and our
our therapeutic cannabis program I've
been to dispensaries in other New
England states and there's one huge
difference between New Hampshire and the
others it is the educational services
available at each dispensary in New
Hampshire in New Hampshire you can walk
right in and have a far more in-depth
level of patient care that is not
matched by other states and you can
easily see this by walking into any
dispensary as I said before you are even
able to see cannabis you are given
several forms to assess each patient's
needs and there are always experts
available for a one-on-one
consultation I've been to other states
this provides not only great resources
to new patients but is a great harm
reduction method as well because we can
actually educate patients and users as
to how to properly use cannabis without
creating a situation for
abuse this the bill before us today
envisions a franchise retail store that
could sell therapeutic cannabis products
to patients but without anywhere near
the same level of
education and with a 15% tax slapped up
on top of that this is insulting to
patients like myself who if you go to
other states pay less or pay no tax on
top of that New Hampshire doesn't tax
other medications so why do we think
it's okay to tax therapeutic cannabis
are we trying to delegitimize the needs
of real patients and eliminate
incentives for people to register for
the therapeutic cannabis program we know
other states uh that have had medical
programs where they introduced
recreational uh programs that
participation in the medical cannabis
programs declined
drastically the same thing will happen
here especially if we don't exemp
patients from the 15% tax and we
shouldn't be surprised if our medical
dispensaries uh are medical only
dispensaries are forced to close their
doors within a few years this this would
be terrible for patients and it
certainly wouldn't be consistent with
the harm reduction approach to
legalization Most states that legalize
cannabis have seen fit to integrate
their existing medical programs with
adult
use improving access for patients while
creating legal access for non-patients
dual use retail stores serve both types
of customers and are common in other
states but they would be prohibited
under this bill Bill instead the bill
would give the same preference to any
cannabis business regardless of where
they are coming from so businesses that
have been here in New Hampshire are not
going to be considered uh as a major
criteria for licensing the other chamber
removed that uh and as a result this
current bill uh seems to be intended to
exclude the alternative treatment
centers from being able to become dual
facility I think we need to be focusing
on keeping the existing companies who've
been operating employing and serving
Granite State Staters for seven years a
single retail license which is all the
atcs have been asking for and before
giving away these licenses to Big
cannabis companies
DHHS has stated that the atc's are an
essential partner in providing care to
the 15,000 plus patients currently in
the program these companies employ over
a 100 granite sters and we should
include them in the future of New
Hampshire cannabis not shut them out
recreational consumers are also going to
get a bad deal too because New Hampshire
is surrounded in all directions by
states with flourishing cannabis markets
does anybody really believe that this
state controlled franchise approach will
serve consumers better than craft
cannabis markets that have been
developing in other states our state as
I said would have a higher tax rate than
all of our neighbors which is the exact
opposite strategy that we use for our
liquor
stores these stores likely won't open
for years and we will likely be unable
to expand it from the 15 locations
meaning that we will be limited people
are going to continue using out ofate
dispensaries to purchase uh or purchase
on the black market because it's cheaper
and it's closer to home finally I think
we need to seriously consider the
possibility that this bill will create
an unworkable boond doggle no state has
ever legally involved itself in the
Cannabis industry before so the
franchise model is legally risky and
could expose our state to unforeseen
liabilities also the other chamber added
a new cannabis Control
Commission that could easily become a
roadblock to implementation
this new commission would not actually
regulate cannabis but it would have veto
authority over all rules and the Liquor
Commission could not present rules to
jail car for approval unless the rules
were first approved by the Cannabis
Control Commission so who would be on
this commission unlike The house's
balanced Advisory Board the commission
appears likely stacked with opponents of
legalization only one of of the 13
members would actually represent the
Cannabis industry and the commission
would also include the president of the
police Chiefs Association the current
commissioner of the AG uh the
Commissioner of Agriculture who strongly
opposes legalization and other likely
opponents how can the Liquor Commission
expect to create a viable Market if
opponents of legalization are able to
block the rulemaking
process even the advocates for
concurrence admit the bill is seriously
flawed they say we need to pass it now
and fix it in the future well if we do
pass it I think we are going to be
creating a lot of problems so many that
many PE uh that many not be possible for
us to fix in the future instead of
rushing to pass a bill that we all know
is flawed a bill that would not even
eliminate position uh possession
penalties until
2026 let's reject this amendment and
insist on making better policies for our
constituents we will only get one chance
to create a well-regulated market for
adult ed cannabis and it's important we
right Mr Speaker this bill is
inconsistent with New Hampshire values
we cannot afford to ignore these
important policy details in our rush to
do something yes our constituents want
legal legalization and so do I but as a
Representatives I believe we have an
obligation to insist on better policies
thank you Mr member he other other
questions no member does not
speaker Mr
Speaker I do have a prepared speech but
I feel really compelled to respond to
what was just
said the atcs are absolutely totally
unaffected by this legislation and as a
matter of fact the reason they're
unaffected is because they pay no
tax do you really think we should have
have a location where some people pay
taxes and some
don't if that is what the atc's want
they could certainly convert and be a
full
franchise there was nothing in here that
stops them from continuing as they are
now
taxfree this
commission this commission was what was
requested
by the those who were opposed to this
legislation who are they well new
Futures and the chief of
police but the funny thing is if you ask
new Futures and chief of police about
this amendment that's coming
over they're going to tell you they
could never get anything better than
this so you could say as well the
opposition said this can't be
good that's the whole point of what the
Senate
did the Senate made this bill the
ugliest most government
intrusive most overregulation
marijuana statute they could mend at the
Midnight
Hour for One Singular
purpose for you to vote no
if you vote no they won they got what
they wanted was to kill this bill to
kill
cannabis they're just dreaming of the
day when cannabis will not be passed for
two four five who knows if it'll ever be
passed as long as the Senate knows that
they can just throw a bunch of crap into
that is the number one reason why you
must vote today and you must vote Yes
because we are not going to get caught
in that Ploy we are going to get
marijuana off the block we've got to get
it
going the reality is it's going to take
two
years two years even before the first
bud is sold in this state we we'll have
two not one two legislative
sessions plenty of opportunities to work
on this piece of well I don't want to
call it what it is but that's call a
enabling legislation for us to begin the
conversation on how we are going to
allow cannabis to be sold in this
state now to the question of let's fix
it later I've never heard of that well
well why don't you come and visit the
Commerce
Committee the Commerce Committee has
been fixing the liquor law every single
session we had Direct shipping we have
self-distribute we today this
year we're dealing with the Homegrown
issue this year we're passing
legislation and
that's something
new if you want to grow a homegrown
there is nothing in this bill that says
you can't grow
home unfortunately when it comes to
these type of laws these are what we
call Mother mayi laws it seems like if
you don't say you can do it that means
you can't do it but I can assure you
that the Liquor Commission never
arrested anybody for distilling in New
Hampshire and the Liquor Commission is
never going to go to anybody's
home that is not their job their job is
to look at the
licenses that's their job they are not
going after New Hampshire
citizens so yes if you want to grow at
home have at it nobody's stopping you
local police might do
that but we can get rid of that if you
pass this bill now
this bill removes decriminalization it
creates
decriminalization it begins the process
of analment it gets what where we all
want to
end I heard on the news or reading the
news this week that more
Americans
seemingly want to have a gummy before
they go to
bed than having a night
cap Now isn't that a good
Yes the motion before us is to occur on
House Bill
1633 Senate Sweeney has asked for a
division this will be a division vote
seats
the mo house will be in
order the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1633 this is a division
vote chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the amended bill before us re Bears
very little resemblance to the very good
bill that this bill passed by a wide
margin in the house and if I know that
this bill does not take effect until
January of 2026 and will continue to
encourage the conga line of cars that
are heading out of state to buy products
leaving as much as $60
million off the table that could be
coming um to us in the state of New
Hampshire in revenue and risking having
dangerous products appear on the market
and continuing criminalization of those
who use cannabis and if I know that the
belief that this new version of the
Cannabis bills bill can simply be fixed
next term is a
fallacy and though I agree with my
esteemed colleague from the castle Down
Yonder that Commerce is an incredible
committee and we do work on a partisan
basis I do not feel that this is fixable
next term and I also agree with my
esteemed colleague that a gummy before
going to bed would be better than a
drink because I don't I only drink on
would I still vote to non-c concur with
this Bill thank you chair recognize
inquiry Mr Speaker as you can see the
Commerce Committee can be a lot of
fun Mr
Speaker if I want to get the Cannabis
cultivators
who are lenses under whatever Bill we
create if I want to get them cultivating
now not five years from now where we
won't have marijuana for seven years Mr
Speaker if I
know that passing this vote today we
will finally begin the clock to have
decriminalization and inment and repair
of the mistake of the marijuana laws
motion the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill
1633 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposer press the red button
[Music]
Harvey representative Harvey I need a
thumb
please all members present have an
opportunity to vote hous will attend to
vote
117 117 voting aay 252 voting nay the
motion
fails representative Richards declared a
conflict of interest and did not vote
for what reason does a member rise make
a motion State your motion non
concur the motion before us now is to
non-c concur on House Bill
1633 a division has been called for
the motion before us is to non-c concur
on House Bill
1633 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposer press the red button
[Music]
represent
Gallagher if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to
vote 173 voting a 196 voting a the
motion
failed for what reason does a member
rise move to form a committee of
conference the motion before us now is
to non-c Concur and form a committee of
conference are you ready for the
question all those
in v has been
requested members should be in their
seats I don't think we lost anybody
motion before us
is to non-c concur inform a committee of
conference this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
voting all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
261 voting nay 108 voting nay the motion
passes chair
recognizes on of the house on behalf of
the on behalf of the House of chair
recognizes representative hunt Ammon
conference chair recognizes the clerk
for a further Senate message Mr speaker
the Senate concurs with the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendments in the passage of
which amendments the Senate as
concurrence to the house house bill
1649 relative to prohibiting certain
products with intentionally added posos
and relative to civil actions for posos
contamination and relative to settlement
of lawsuits against manufacturers of
keos for impacts to public drinking
water
systems represent hunt moves we Concur
okay this is the last
one um so in this particular bill um
which is obviously controversial pasas
but um I think it's been a real showing
of our bipartisan work to get this right
uh the Senate did uh kind of loosen up
on the definition a little bit but I
talked to the sponsor and she was okay
with it and so at least now we do have
something on the books that we'll at
least uh have a process I would say for
everybody who's wondering where it came
from this is modeled after the Mercury
when we uh regul started regulating
mercury in the state of New Hampshire so
please vote
Yes motion before us is occur on House
Bill 1649
FN did I division has been requested
members take your
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1649 FN this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house attend to St the
passes chair recogniz the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
pastor the following title bill with
Amendment and the passage of which
amendments the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 135 relative to
warrant representative Roy moves that we
rhods thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the language that the house originally
adopted was taken directly from the
Federal statute that was implemented by
the B
Administration we passed that
unanimously on the consent
calendar then the friends over there
made an amendment to this and what they
did was they added that in order for a
no knock warrant although they would not
be completely outlawed they will be
greatly restricted an officer has to be
in complete uniform they have to use um
they have to be very verbal and let the
let the people know that they are
actually
there to do that and additionally if
there is reason to believe that an
officer is going to be physically
injured or harmed then in order to not
have to go through these these other
prerequisites they actually have to have
permission from the judicial branch and
from the police of uh chief of police
excuse me and we would ask that you vote
to
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 135 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
passes chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
the house house bill 593 establishing a
committee to study the process for
forfeiture of items used in connection
representative roads Mo we concur chair
recognizes as representative roads and
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
when this bill originally came to our
committee uh myself and I think
everybody else that was there that day
thought that we actually uh were handed
a published novel and we were all a
little bit confused a little bit
overwhelmed what we were looking at and
after we thought maybe it would be best
to interim study this particular Bill we
thought that that actually wasn't very
fair that you know we really didn't
understand all of the content it was
very
overwhelming and fortunately for us we
had the opportunity to have the
honorable retired Supreme Court Justice
with us there that day who ended up
doing a lot of our work so uh upon
further discussion we decided
to basically make this into a study
committee with the understanding that I
will not be on that study committee Mr
Speaker and um Additionally the the
changes that were made is basically
making this a house study committee only
there won't be anybody else on there
except house members and we would ask
that you please
concur the motion before us to concur on
House Bill 593 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion
passes chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the fallowing entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate as the concurrence of the
house house bill 596 prohibiting the use
of racial profiling and law enforcement
royes representative Roy moves that we
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker uh
this is another bill that we passed on
the consent calendar that we worked in
our committee to get the language
correct and the change that was made is
because New Hampshire does not have a
requirement for
self-identification that if there is an
investigation that during that
investigation that the officers involved
are able to actually use physical
characteristics in their in their
descriptions when they're discussing
that and there was also um the annual
report is going to be due on November of
2024 the motion for Ur on House Bill 596
FN are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I oppose nay you
guys have it motion is
adopted jerich and Isaac clerk for a
message Mr Speaker the Senate URS of the
house and the passage of the following
titled bill of amendment in the passage
of which amendment the Senate has the
concurrence of the house house bill 653
relative to providing additional duties
to the interbranch criminal and Juvenile
Justice
Council representative Roy moves that we
speak I believe I might have been set up
um I believe this is the uh Bill where
we requested that uh members be assigned
to uh a juvenile justice study committee
and there was really nothing
substantially added to that other than
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 653 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say
I oppos nay eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled with Amendment the
passage of which amend of the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
privacy
speak representative Roy moves that we
Muse thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I urge you to oppose
the request of the other body to concur
with HB
1186 the bill would require our attorney
general to pursue legal action against
financial institutions and credit card
companies who allow a merchant code for
firearms and ammunition per purchases to
be used in New Hampshire as amended by
the other body it would also allow the
Attorney General to pursue legal action
against gun dealers who use these
codes industry specific Merchant
category code C or mcc's are four-digit
numbers set up by the international
standards organization that identify the
primary purpose of a business these
codes are in widespread use for other
types of purchases ranging from
restaurant meals to toys to snowmobile
dealers to
gasoline in addition to helping
determine the eligibility of a purchase
for rewards programs these codes are
integrated into algorithms that are used
to flag credit card purchases that may
be
fraudulent the gun and ammunition store
code in question allows Banks and credit
card companies to develop rules-based
transaction monitoring systems without
drastically altering their internal
systems for coding and processing
transactions what bringing gun and
ammunition re retailers into the payment
system would do is pretty simple it
would allow banks that provide services
to firearm Merchants uh and payment
options to to Consumers to more
accurately detect fraud and suspicious
activity and to report it to law
enforcement for follow-up investigation
and
intervention as someone who's had his
credit card information stolen multiple
times over the years I don't consider
things that Banks and credit card
companies do to detect fraud and
suspicious activity to be a violation of
my
privacy what I do consider them to be is
an essential part of their
responsibility to help me avoid being
the victim of a
crime something else that's worth noting
is that these codes uh all they do is
really list the category that the
purchase falls into so in the case of
the Firearms Merchants code all it will
tell you is that something was purchased
from a merchant who has assigned this
code it won't tell you how many guns
what type of guns how long you've wanted
to own that particular gun or how much
ammunition you
purchased it also won't tell you if the
gun was new or used or if it was an AR15
or a daringer the bottom line is that
the bottom line is that if this is a gun
registry which supporters of the bill
claim it would be the most useless gun
registry
ever the bill is not about protecting
privacy it's about protecting the
entitlement of an entire industry to
operate without a trace of
accountability for any form of Public
Safety this is a bill that will make it
easier for gun traffickers potential
Mass Shooters illegal straw purchasers
and criminals who fraudulently run up
charges on other people's credit cards
to commit crimes it is also a bill that
the Department of Justice tells us will
require an additional part-time
investigator and a part time attorney to
implement at a cost of approximately
$90,000 a year please vote no on the
motion to concur by pressing the red
button thank you chair recognize
representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I I
am really sorry that my friend from Port
Smith's credit card information was
stolen but I can guarantee you it wasn't
for purchasing a firearm
um I would
point out that this is not about
Firearms only think about this for a
second they're not doing this to track
fish and rods they're not doing it to
track tents they're not doing it to
track cars bicycles basketballs only
Firearms now we just got into a little
thing here about marijuana now what if
the federal government started putting a
code on your purchases for marijuana
what if they started putting codes on
other things that the federal government
decide they didn't let like and they
could track who purchased it and who had
it a lot of bad things could happen with
that if you happen to have a CDL license
and you drive a truck when you go out
and you purchase our legal marijuana
guess what that little code can lead
back to your CDL license being revoked
and that goes on and on for many many
things this is about Firearms yet first
you know my friend said well it's really
about um credit card safety but then he
went on to say it's about Public Safety
which is it it's not about that it's
about the federal government tracking
what we do on a microscopic level and we
at a state where we very rarely have
control over things like this have an
opportunity to say no not in New
Hampshire I would ask you to concur
thank
you motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 11
186 a division has sen who represent ask
for a roll call is sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
was
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 11
186 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Harriet
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill is not about protecting
privacy and if I know it's definitely
not about protecting Public Safety and
will only increase the risk of gun
trafficking mass shooting and fraudulent
use of credit cards in our state then
would I press the red button so another
motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know it's not
about public safety and I know it's not
about business safety I I I don't know I
I would suggest that it is about yes the
government not tracking what we
purchase and I would suggest that you
vote with me and concur thank
you motion before us to concur on House
Bill
1186 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
Brown all members present had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
vote 190 voting a 179 voting a the
motion
is chair recognizes the clerk for a
report Mr Speaker the committee on
enrolled bills has examed and found
correctly en rolled the following titled
bills house bills 182 370 1109 and 1160
and Senate bills 329 377 424 430 443 498
599 the house will be in recess for
lunch for 1
hour back be back here right at 1:00 we
do
e
for Senate messages thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house in their amendments sent
up to the following bills Senate Bill
476 and Senate Bill 532 and Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in
their amendments to the following title
bills sen up from the house senate bills
137 236 310 10 311 318 324 327 331 337
338 352 355 369 372 378 383 388 391 393
402 403 404 406 409 433 435 441 449 451
455 463 473 497 502 508 528 539 542 544
545 547 556 559 572 585 591 592 595 600
604 chair recogniz the cler forer the
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 1014 relative to
instruction in government and Civics
including information on Election laws
and voting and requiring certain
educational institutions and local
government to use a holiday statutorily
designated title in official
Communications Publications and
representative lad moves
concurrence and is recognized to speak
to his
motion thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I want to thank the senate for
sending us another boatload of
bills um HB
1014 to
require that schools colleges
universities and all local government
agencies use a holiday statutory
designation title in official commun
Communications Publications and
concur a division has been requested
all right the motion before us is
concurrence on House Bill
1014 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Damon for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the original
House Bill 1014 Bill focused on
educating students about elections
voting and voter registration and if I
know the body on the other side of the
wall added language dealing with
designated holidays that is totally
irrelevant to the bill if I know that
this change would create an unfunded
mandate by requiring the updating of all
official communication from all
municipalities schools and other
government agencies to modify their
websites newsletters calendars and any
Communications regarding holiday naming
and and lastly if I know that this
change in House Bill 1014 is not
necessary would I vote no on the concur
motion so another better motion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative lad for a
parliamentary thank you very much Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know New
Hampshire law currently names and
identifies 10 holidays in the state
Martin Luther King Day Civil Rights Day
Washington's birthday Memorial Day
Independence Day Labor Day Columbus Day
Veterans Day Thanksgiving Day and
Christmas Day and if I further know HB
1014 as amended reinforces the point
that these holidays have so been
designated by the state and that it's
unacceptable for any institution or
local government to place itself Above
the Law by designating or replacing a
statutory holiday or name with another
name would I then support the
recommendation to concur by pressing the
green
button motion before us to concur on
House Bill 1014 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 183 voting a 171 voting a the
chair Rec andiz clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following entitled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1107 relative to
Frameworks represent vad moves that we
thank you Mr Speaker if I know 1107 as
Modified by the sen Senate made only one
change to it the bill is about
curriculum Frameworks and the curriculum
Frameworks shall contain the academic
standards for each subject area in their
wisdom the Senate did contribute
something that's beneficial to us where
this review of these curriculum
Frameworks must be done every 10 years
we're now sitting with frame works that
are back to 2002 2003 with no update
since so I recommend concurrence here
the motion before is concurrence on
House Bill 10 11107 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house House Bill
1165 relative to procedures for school
Education representative lad moves that
we concurrent is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh 1165 is Bill
dealing with the public school
infrastructure commission and that's a
commission which we appropriate each
bium money for security safety access
egress everything from these schools to
keep them
safe what this has been what they Senate
did in the amending change is also uh
requiring the recommendations that come
from that Commission in the past we've
had to get approval from both fiscal and
from the governor's councel they
eliminated the governor's Council which
is advantageous to getting these things
done quickly so in the summertime we can
get these projects out to the
contractors to get going so it will save
us a couple weeks during the summer not
having to wait for Governor's Council to
say yes and they've never said no to any
of the recommendations so I ask for
concurrence motion before us to concur
on House Bill 1165 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
motion Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 1305 relative to freedom of
speech and Association of public
education representative lad moves that
we concur on House Bill
1305 a division has been requested
who requested the roll
call roll call has been requested by
seconded it is s it is sufficiently
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1305 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative luno for
inquiry thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know the bill would mandate our
state universities and community
colleges to sponsor student groups that
discriminate against others to the very
same extent that these organizations
sponsor other student
groups and if I know recently what began
as peaceful peaceful demonstrations on
college campuses across the country
escalated inter and interfered with
classes and even commencement but not at
our state colleges and universities and
and if I know that our current Free
Speech policies are among the best in
the country and help ensure a safe and
productive environment for students and
families then would I press the red
button and impose this Bill thank
you J recognize represent a wheel for a
problem
agree thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that freedom of speech is a core
tenant to our Republic and that no
student should lose their right to
freedom of speech when they enter a
campus then would I vote to concur with
the legislation before us thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us to concur on
House Bill
1305 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos or press the red button
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay the
vote do one voting yay 160 voting nay
the
motioned jerck and Isaac clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the following entitled bill with
Amendment passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill
1579 relative to the merging of school
units representative Lab news are we
Concur and is recogniz to speak to his
motion thank you very much Mr Speaker uh
hb1 1579 is a bill that uh encourages
saus to merge their administrative
Services what this bill does it extends
the time in which to do it from
2026 to 2030 so it jumps the time to re
receive these dollars to merge by four
years give mergers that time to take
place I urge you to
concur a motion before us is concur on
House Bill 1579 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it the motion
is
adopted chair recogniz clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate occurs with the house and the
passage the following in title bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1655
including in the commissioner of the
Department of education's rulemaking
authority the authority to make rules
regarding collection of fees for
processing representative lad and Jian
move that we Concur and his
speak HB 1655 is a recommended from both
committees uh it's a very simple change
which the Senate has made uh in uh
giving the commissioner the authority to
charge for these fees they've changed
the language from quote for the
processing of criminal history record
checks to for the processing of criminal
history record check clearances we
recommend
concurrence motion before is to concur
on House Bill
1655 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 115 relative to
election Representative Steven Smith
moves that we concur
Lane thank you Mr
Speaker well so here we are again those
who want a June primary are definitely
persistent we have already voted down a
June primary on the second Tuesday twice
once in January and once in
May and now we need to vote down the
third Tuesday in June changing the date
by one week in order to avoid the
indefinite postponement vote on May 2nd
makes no difference to those of us who
voted against a June primary June
is June we want
August let me remind you why we have
overwhelmingly killed a June primary
twice this
year it means yearlong campaigning for
our constituents to endure and frankly
for us to
endure we start in January with the town
offices you register you run for three
months then in March you if you're going
to be a State Rep or a state senator you
have to register and then run for that
office too when you're done in June
which means that we would all be
campaigning right
now when you're done in June then you
get to campaign to
November frankly I'm glad I live in a
city and not a town because we vote in
different years but we will have both
constituent and candidate fatigue if
anything it may discourage people from
running for state
representative also this will increase
campaign costs longer time to campaign
means you're going to be spending more
money making it even more expensive to
run for State Rep than it is
now again this house has spoken twice on
this
issue Let the Body on the other side of
the wall know
that we are determined so please send
them a message for the third time that
we do not want a June primary no matter
which Tuesday in June it is thank
you chair recognize Representative
Steven Smith Mr
Speaker I'm sorry I wanted to request a
you thank you Mr Speaker
speaker we we've heard all these
arguments and I'm not going to rehash it
yeah so now it's a different day in June
that's what's before you but I do want
to address one thing I I think we
campaign differently so when we're not
in campaign mode I still go in my
district and take care of local issues I
still go to a select board meeting when
I'm asked to I just handled an issue
with a bridge in my town I go places I
experience what the people experience I
don't have to wait until July to do that
I know that in my district the best subs
are of course at Corona's Market often
imitated never equals if you if you
don't know that you're going to have
trouble running in Newport and you don't
have to wait till July to go there I
know which of the two pizza places in
that town you go to if you want the
pizza or the calzone I go to veterans
events I don't ever stop doing those
things because I don't ever stop stop
being the representative it doesn't cost
a lot of money that's how I do it I
don't know what you guys are spending on
but if you're blowing thousands of
dollars on mailers maybe just get out a
little more so anyway I hope you can
support the motion to
concur the motion before is to concur on
house
bill5 this is a division vote members
s
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 115 this is a division vote
chair recogniz representative bone for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that hb15
came from this body with a 70% vote for
the primary to be in August and should
be law now and if I know that we
indefinitely postponed sp sp 380 and
this amendment amended bill is only
about one word different from that bill
and if I know that I believe in State's
rights and as such we should not be
mandated by a National Organization of
what they want and if I know that the
current law does not benefit
incumbents if so then why aren't
Republicans still in Congress like they
were and if I know that a June primary
will only benefit persons that have the
most money for five months of TV ads
instead of just two so just remember
what we did with sb380 and do the same
with this identical Bill vote red so we
can non-c concur thank you
chair recognize representative Sweeney
for parament inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that 70% of
this body is in favor of moving our
state primary earlier in the year and Mr
Speaker if I further know that we in
this body are in favor of early August
and the body on the other side of the
wall is in favor of early June and that
this compromise amendment is in between
the two dates would I now press the
green button to Concur and do what 70%
of this body wants which is move the
state primary sooner thank you very much
motion before us is ur on House Bill 115
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members present are obtaining a vote
vote 159 voting a 202 voting a the
motion
fails yeah you
got for what reason does it member rise
I would move non-c concur Mr Speaker the
motion before is to non-c concur on
House Bill 115 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I
concurrence Jer and Isa clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate occurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 243
requiring the tabulation of votes in
Representative Steve Smith moves that we
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh there are
no significant changes from the other
side of the wall they changed our
language long report tapes to printed
results from the voting machine probably
better off I don't know how long as long
and hand counting to hand counts that's
it so I urge the body to concur
the motion before is to concur on House
Bill 243 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I iose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked concurrence
of the house house bill 1098 relative to
ballots delivered to Elder Care Facility
represent Steven Smith moves at we
concur in House Bill
1098 and is recognized to speak thank
you Mr Speaker the change from the
mystical land Beyond replaces Shon Shore
with shallon Shore to the extent
possible that seems reasonable I urge
a division has been requested members
com
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1098 this is a division vote
chair recognized represent award for
parliamentary
iny thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this well-meaning but
unnecessary bill has now been rendered
completely unacceptable to our
hardworking City and town clerks by the
amendment from from the other body
requiring requiring their insertion and
active participation into the absentee
ballot voting process for nursing home
and Elder Care residents at a completely
inappropriate granular timec consuming
level that is inconsistent with their
position and duties and actually places
them in potential Jeopardy and if I know
all that would I then press the red
button to overturn this motion so that a
more proper motion may be made thank you
Mr Speaker I request a division
vote chair recogniz representive Steven
Smith for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that activities regarding voting are
already going on in these facilities and
people there have volunteered to do them
Mr Speaker if I know whether it's hard
or not it's important to ensure that
these activities that they're already
doing are conducted in a fair and
appropriate manner then would I press
the green button to
concur motion before is to concur when
house bill 1098 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos press the
red button voting stations are open for
all members present have the opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
182 voting yay 181 voting nay and the
vote chair recognizes the clerk for a uh
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the pass of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
11:26 relative to candidate request for
Step Smith moves we concurrent is
speak thank you Mr
Speaker the extent of the change to this
bill is the word absentee ballot is
changeed to absentee ballot envelope for
the purposes of the bill it's the same
thing please
concur the motion before us to concur on
House Bill 11:26 are you ready are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say I iose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
chair recogniz the clerk forer the
Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 1150 relative to advertising
advertising res Steven Smith moves that
thank you Mr
Speaker with the
amendment the ad rate filing requirement
that was contained in the bill is still
removed so getting that burden off of
people one thing we wanted we didn't get
was a requirement to Mark political ad
on political ads they restored the
requirement to do that we got half of
what we asked for I don't believe that
our position would improve a committee
of conference so I ask you to
concur the motion before is concur in
House Bill 1150 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppos
nay eyes have it the motion is adopted
chair recogniz the clerk for further
Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
Fong entitled bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
has the concurrence of the house house
bill 1310 relative relative to meetings
checklist stemon Smith moves that we
speak thank you Mr
Speaker so the only change is that we
had an exemption from public notice of
reconvened and adjourned meetings that
came out the rest of it is fine so close
enough I urge the body to concur the
division has been requested members take
your
motion before us is concurrent House
Bill 1310 this is a division vote chair
recognized represent Ward for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill requires meetings of the
supervisors of the checklist to occur
every 90 days a mandate that somehow is
redundant on the one hand and un needed
on the other because if I also know that
in most cities the supervisors and
registrars already meet more than that
at least once a month in my city but if
I also know that in many towns there is
absolutely no need to meet so often
given the small voter pool and thus this
bill places an unnecessary burden on
those public servants and if I know in
addition that the supervisors are
already required by law to meet at
several important times dictated by the
election calendar and also at the
request of the secretary of state but I
then press the red button to overturn
this attempt at micromanagement that in
truth serves no useful purpose thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognize quy for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill as passed by the house
ensures
that supervisors of the checklist beat
on a regular basis to keep the checklist
up to date
but that it also included an exemption
from public notice if
reconvening an already adjourned meeting
of the supervisor of the checklist and
that the only difference between the
position of the house and the position
of the Senate is that the Senate removed
that exemption from public notice for
reconvening an adjourned meeting and
furthermore if I know that in the
interest of uh transparency in public
knowledge of when
meetings of the supervisors of the
checklist occurred that this is a
reasonable change on the part of the
Senate would I then press the green
button to vote Yes and
concur uh with the Senate with the other
body's changes thank you motion before
is to concur on House Bill 1310 this the
vision vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
while members president had an
opportunity to vote I'll attend to stay
the
vote 183 voting yay 180 voting nay the
motion
is chair recogniz the clerk for a
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate has the concurrence of the house
house bill 494 renaming the Agricultural
Product and scale testing fund at the
representative Aaron and J Jian move
that we Concur and chair recognizes
representative Aaron to
speak thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon
everyone uh the uh other body made a
very simple change to this housekeeping
Bill uh changed the effective date from
July July 1st 2024 to July 1st
2025 so I we recommend concurrence on
this Bill thank
you the motion before us to concur on
House Bill
494 FN are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recogniz the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate conures of the house in the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence to the house house bill 1221
relative to including solid wastel
landfills in the definition of
impact representative Aaron moves that
we concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you again Mr
Speaker so the other body removed the
provision in this bill uh for our
secretary of state to
contact uh another State's Secretary of
State if there were a project such as a
landfill um in in causing some sort of
regional impact and so that provision
was removed and our committee was okay
with that uh with that removal so we
recommend concur on this Bill thank
you a motion before us to concur on
House Bill 1221 are you ready for the
question question all those in favor say
I I oppose nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted chair recognize the
clerk for further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
and the passage of the following titled
bill of amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as concurs of the
house house bill
1626 relative to the repeal of certain
designated funds and relative to the
fees OB sen Aron move that week Concur
and as recognized as
speak thank you again Mr
Speaker so with this bill um we have a
statute for animal a animal population
control and in that provision we allow
currently or the bill had specified
80% of the cost of neuter and spay for
folks who were unable to pay or were on
Medicaid or um had were Beyond below
poverty level and so forth that um they
the veterinarian would be getting
reimbursed 80% from the state fund and
the other body changed that to be 100%
uh reimbursement to the veterinarian for
performing that procedure and we our
committee uh accepted that change and we
recommend concurrence on this Bill thank
you motion before us to concur on House
Bill 1626 FNA are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the commit the report is adopted chair
recogniz that clerk for a further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate curs with
the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 274 relative to the
representative Carol McGuire moves that
speak thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
274 is
a measure to improve the visibility and
the notices for the rul making process
the Senate made essentially two changes
first they defined stakeholders a great
deal better than the house was able
to uh and secondly they said that if a
person agreed by a rule Sues and it is
found that and it is found that the rule
is not
applicable the house had said that their
legal fees shall be paid the Senate
changed that to May allowing some
discretion for the judges the committee
feels those are minor changes and
acceptable to us and we hope you will
agree
motion before us is to ur on House Bill
274 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I oppose nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
chair recogniz the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house and the passage
of the following titled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate as the concurrence of a house
house bill 1057 relative to provisional
licenses for new applicants for State
mire Carol Maguire moves that we Concur
speak thank you Mr Speaker this bill
allows a uh an EMT to get a provisional
license and work while their criminal
records check is being processed the
Senate Amendment added some reasonable
precautions for supervision during dur
that period which the house thought was
the normal process and
didn't didn't feel the need to to
specify but we're not we have no
objection to it I hope you will
agree the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1057 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes hav't and the motion
is adopted chair recognizing clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following title bill with
Amendment the pass which amendment the
Senate has concurrence of the house
house bill 1059 relative to the State
Building
Code Senator Carol McGuire moves that we
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
merely changed the date of the building
code review board amendments that are
approved by this
bill with it supports the house position
that the energy code update is not
included because and it's purely a
housekeeping measure I hope you will
on there the motion before us is to
concur on House Bill 1059 there has been
a request for a division members take
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill
1059 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposer press the red button
[Music]
repres
all members present opportunity to vote
house attend to stay the
vote 319 voting a 43 voting a motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask the concurrence
of the house house spill 1095 relative
to the administrative of occupation
boards by the office of professional LIC
Insurance certification repres Carol
mgu
recognized representative Carol McGuire
speak good morning this is House Bill
1095 is a lot of cleanup of a large
number of Licensing statutes that
nobody else knows because it all pass
the house on consent a couple of times
the Senate made two significant changes
one they made sure that if you're being
licensed as a journeyman or a master
electrician in addition to the test and
the apprenticeship you also have to have
a minimum amount of classroom time which
is included in all of the programs we
know about so we don't have any problems
with that it also simplified the process
of applying for a um Master's licensed
alcohol and drug counselor application
and it would say that if you are
determined not to be qualified for that
license they will grant you a licensed
alcohol and drug counselor license which
is the step below without further fee
and the committee feels that's perfectly
reasonable I hope you will
concur motion before us concur in House
Bill 1095 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those close
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair Rec andiz a clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
in the pass of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1222 relative to the
physician assistant scope of practice
and establishing a committee to research
practice representative Carol Maguire
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table this bill okay
that is a proper motion the motion
two22
minute a division has been requested
members take your seats not yet just a
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 1222 this is a division vote chair
recogniz representative tles for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that physician
assistants are important and valued
members of healthcare teams whose
current training does not prepare them
for independent practice even with 8,000
hours of unsupervised collaborative
practice and that this bill fails to
address key dimensions for quality and
safety specifically determination of
competence and scope of practice and if
I know that HB 1222 needs further work
and should not be rushed as this is a
complex issue that requires thoughtful
study then then would I now press the
green t green button to table this bill
and I ask for a division vote chair
recogniz representative gr for a
parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the
committee exhaustedly reviewed this bill
we had subcommittee hearings and we
discussed it
thoroughly and we voted and we presented
a house floor amendment that that led to
a Voice vote that passed this house and
if I know that the Senate added further
restrictions to physician assistance in
their amendment that we want to concur
with would I not table and vote red
thank
you motion before us table House Bill
1222 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're in poos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open in 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
favors we're now back to the motion to
concur the chair recognizes
representative
Simon representative signman is ways
off the chair recognize representative
toise
Speaker physician assistants are
important and valued members of
healthcare teams across the state and
have provided excellent care to my
family an independent practice is a
understandable good goal and HP 1222
needs further work it should not be
rushed through I'm a trained Health
Services researcher and have spent my
whole professional life working to
increase access to and quality of Health
Care especially for the most vulnerable
and underserved thus I understand the
motivation for this bill to address
Workforce shortages in our state however
this bill needs further work and should
not be rushed this is a complex issue
and this bill fails to address quality
and safety issues related to competence
and scope of
practice to contrast Physicians MDS and
Do's and nurse practitioners must
demonstrate competence within a scope of
practice prior to practicing
independently physician assistants who
have significantly less training should
be held to the same standard for
assuring
competence as it stands this bill
essentially grants special status to
physician assistant first by not
requiring them to demonstrate competence
with a certification exam and assessment
process after completing the proposed
8,000 hours of unsupervised practice and
second by not delineating a scope of
practice meaning someone who completed
8,000 hours such as in Urgent Care could
open a practice in a different area such
as neurology or surgery or Primary Care
thus this issue Merit thoughtful study
independent practice is very complicated
and must be appropriately studied before
expanding inde dependent practice so we
can take the necessary time to
understand all the implications and make
sure we get it right I urge you to vote
against concurrence and Mr Speaker I ask
Simon thank you Mr Speaker I we haveed
off and here I am back again um I'm
hoping that the tabling motion vote uh
is what we're basically looking at I
don't want to take up tooo much time on
this particular bill um but the Senate
Amendment adds an 8,000 hour um
requirement so that they'll have to put
in 8 8,000 hours of practice before they
can ask for a waiver from the Board of
Medicine to practice independently
whatever um they're going to be
practicing the Board of Medicine is
going to have to approve that uh so it's
not like it's a free-for-all they do
their 8,000 hours and then they can just
practice independently um they will have
to ask for a waiver from the Board of
Medicine the Board of Medicine is going
to have to look at each individual
person who's applying for that waiver um
review their credentials whether or not
um they are qualified to to work
independently and then approve it what
we have right now is just um a
collaboration agreement that every
Physician's assist assistant has to sign
um with a physician in order to practice
many times those Physicians are nowhere
in the building they may not even be in
the state um it's a piece of paper
that's signed I have a physician
assistant uh who's been practicing for
over 20 years in Littleton who has to
pay $20,000 a year for that signed piece
of paper uh
$20,000 in order to have that uh we have
doctors who are now opening up
businesses just to sign these
collaboration agreements because there's
so much money in it um and so for those
reasons uh I would ask that you would
allow physici assistance to work within
the scope as determined by the Board of
Medicine um and please concur with this
thank
you the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1222 a division has has been
motion before concur on H Bill 1222 this
is going to be a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay the
vote 325 voting a 36 voting a motion is
adopted chair recogniz the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1307
providing a supplemental appropriation
for members of the retirement system
receiving an accidental disability
retirement
allowance representative Carol McGuire
moves that we Concur and is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
made some minor formatting changes to
this bill which we have no problem with
and they move the payment from fiscal
year 24 to fiscal year
25 which considering how much of FIS
fiscal year 24 we have left gives them a
little more time to get their work done
will motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1307 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognize
message Mr Speaker the Senate curs of
the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate ask the currence of the house
house bill
1328 relative to Public Safety providers
defined as essential
services mgu
represenative Carol Maguire moves that
speak thank you Mr Speaker the Senate
again did some Ming changes the most
important part was that they made sure
that volunteer First Responders such as
the firefighters we have in most of our
towns are also counted as essential
services
the uh the committee agrees with that
redef that clarification and hopes you
well the motion before us is to ur on
House Bill
1328 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recogniz the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS of the house in the passage
of the following titled bill with
amendment in the pass of which amendment
the Senate as concurrence of the house
house bill
1352 relative to firefighting personal
protective
equipment sen Carol McGuire moves at we
con Cur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker again the
Senate did some uh minor word minor word
smithing and they also simplified the
definition of what is to be banned so
that would have less effect on the um
local fire
department the it me fully meets the
intent of the bill and we hope you will
support these
changes the motion before us is to ur on
House Bill
1352 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose
nayay guys have it and a motion is
adopted
chair recogniz at clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
conures with the house in the passage of
the following title bill of amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate has the concurrence of the house
house bill
1385 relative to establishing a veteran
licensing acceleration program and
therefore pres Carol McGuire moves that
we Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker again and the
Senate uh made some minor changes they
changed a chapter heading to agree with
the uh the new effort and the sponsor
and the Edna committee both agree that
that supports the intent of the bill and
we hope you will support it
also the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1385 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes a
message Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following en titled bill with
amendment in passage of which amendment
the Senate asked the concurrence to the
house house bill 1410 relative to
certain professional licenses and
relative to the board of Optometry and
the regulation of
representative Maguire moves that we
concur for what reason does a member
rise to make motion the house will be in
order State your motion to table House
Bill
1410 the motion is to table House Bill
1410 a division has been requested
CC
the motion before us is a table the
seats the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1410 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Nagel for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker if I
know everything that I knew when I made
the motion on Senate 440 which we
discussed two weeks ago a motion that
passed 224 to
137 which is now present in House Bill
1420 and if I know that the current
before us bill before us is lacking in
subjective legislative or stakeholder
review and if I know that this bill
Beyond suggesting who has the right to
to perform eye surgery has the
unintended consequence of creating a
paradigm shift in who can perform
surgery of any type in effect that has
not been discussed or considered finally
that may be why I know that legislation
allowing optometrist to practice surgery
such as we are discussing now has failed
112 times since
2012 and no state in the Northeast
allows it then I would press the green
button to join West Virginia Missouri
Kansas Utah Idaho California Vermont
Minnesota and Nebraska who have all
rejected such legislation this year and
please table this motion thank you chair
recogniz representative Sweeny for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the underlying bill of HB 410
was a house pass bill that we do care
about in the House of Representatives
and further Mr Speaker if I know today
our job is to concur nonon concur or
form Committees of conferences would I
now press the red button to keep this
bill from our overflowing table and have
a proper debate and vote on the actual
motions at hand thank you very much the
motion before us is the table House Bill
1410 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
your opposer press the red button voting
[Music]
represent
wary while members present have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 192 voting a 170 voting a h Bill
1410 is laid on the table
chair recognizes a clerk for further
Senate Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which M the Senate as the
concurrence of the house house bill 1413
relative to mental health supervision
agreements and relative to establishing
a committee to study increasing access
services president Carol Maguire moves
that we concur
on House Bill
1413 are you ready for the
question and recognize this I recognize
representative Carol
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker on House
Bill 13 1413 the Senate added a study
committee on barriers to Mental Health
Access now normally I'm not a fan of
study committees and and I'm very glad
that this one does not include a
mandatory member from Edna but when we
were hearing this bill we found out that
the statutes were being read differently
by different people that what the
insurance companies interpreted wasn't
always what the board interpreted and
what or what the professionals
interpreted so I think this is an area
that could actually use some study and I
hope that you all agree and they made no
changes to the rest of the bill just add
of the study
committee motion before us is to concur
on House Bill
14113 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
adopted chair recogniz the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill for 1456
relative to the appointment and removal
of the members of the board of tax and
board representative Carol Maguire moves
that we Concur and is recognized speak
motion thank you Mr Speaker other than
some minor language changes the main
difference to the that the Senate made
to this bill was
to extend the terms of the board of tax
and land appeals to five years which
they used to be rather than the current
three years that's something we
discussed in committee but I have to say
nobody thought it was important enough
to actually write an amendment so we
didn't pass it the Senate thought
differently but we can't argue with that
position and I hope you will support it
also question before the house is the
motion to concur on 1456 you ready for
the question all in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no and the motion's
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has concurrence of
the house house bill
1474 relative to the commission on
Affairs representative Carol McGuire
moves that we Concur and as recognized
thank you Mr Speaker this house bill
made a number of changes to the
membership of this this uh commission
and uh expanded their scope a bit and
fixed the Quorum because the commission
has been unable to meet effectively for
years because they haven't been able to
get a proper Quorum there aren't enough
members
appointed and in place to have a meeting
so the Senate instead of just killing
this bill which was their first choice
decided to remove everything except the
Quorum fix so all this bill does now is
give this commission an effective Quorum
so they can do their business and if
they and I hope you will agree that that
was the main point of the bill and we
hope you will support it the questions
on the motion to con on House Bill 1474
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppos nay
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
shair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
1526 relative to a conditional
Veterinary license for graduat of a
non-av accredited colleges or excuse me
colleges of veterinary medicine
representative Carol Maguire moves that
the house concurrent is recognized speak
to a
motion thank you Mr Speaker again the
Senate made a number of wording and
formatting changes but the main intent
of their amendment is to ensure that
these foreign veterinarians while they
are
working to get their license and under
this provisional license will have
direct supervision of a license
veterinarian who will verify their their
immigration and employment
status we think that is a reasonable
restriction and we hope you will support
it the questions on the motion to concur
on House Bill 1526 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay I have it on the
Motions adopted the chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate messenger Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
in the passage of the following entitled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask to the house
hit
1647 relative to the calculation of
group two retirement benefits in the
retirement
system and representatives Maguire and
Wier move that the house
concur representative Maguire has
speak thank you Mr Speaker this bill was
to
restore Fire group two that is
firefighters and police
who were employed but not vested in 2011
to the previous state of retirement
benefits the Senate tweaked it quite
drastically
to space it out and not apply to new
[Music]
hires uh but it's they also cut the cost
in half to down to 26 million and
the chairman of the finance committee
and others I've spoken to agree with me
that this is probably all we're going to
get this year
so if we you want to take this half a
pound vote to
concur the questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill 1647 you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppos nay I have on the
Motions adopted the chair recogniz the
clerk for further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs of the house
in the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendment in the passage of
which amendment the Senate as it concurs
of the house house bill
1323 relative to the Furnishing of
copies of the State Constitution by the
Secretary of State to the public
representative wer moves at the house
speaker thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1323 was a simple Bill to produce a
pocket-sized con Constitution without
information that expires every two years
like elected officials so it would be
ready for a longer time when we amended
it
we referred to section RSA 5 and we
added RSA 5A it turns out that a was
deleted in 1959 so they changed it to
RSA 5B they also uh didn't took out the
appropriation because the Secretary of
State already has the the uh fund and
also the effective date he can do
whenever he's ready we request that you
support and concur on 1323 very little
change thank you the questions on the
motion to concur on House Bill 1323
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay eyes
have it the motion is adopted and the
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
URS at the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 322 relative to establishing
a committee to study the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine and making an
appropriation to the Department of
Services representative Wayne McDonald
moves at the house concurrent as
recognized
speak thank you Mr Speaker the house
bill 322 uh set out to establish a
committee to study the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine and uh make an
appropriation to the Department of
Health and Human Service
the Senate um revised it um and offered
an amendment a very specific Amendment
and a very limited Amendment and I'll
just read what it says it appropriates
$750,000 to the Department of Health and
Human Services for the purpose of making
a one-time one-time payment to any
licensed Nursing Facility serving
individuals covered by Medicaid with a
change in ownership during fiscal year
23 whose daily Medicaid rate has
remained below the state average for the
period from July 1st
2022 through J through January 1st
2024 the appropriation is for the fiscal
year 24 and 25 bium it's a very specific
very limited uh thing it's designed to
help nursing facilities which we do have
an aging population in New Hampshire
it's a very narrowly focused
appropriation it's a onetime
appropriation and the fact is everybody
can't keep their relatives at home as
they age and the nursing home industry
has gone through some rough times
particularly because of covid so I'd ask
concur the questions on the motion to
concur anoun Bill 322 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
keep the doors closed members in the
chamber take your
all
right there's no there's no piis on a
clarification
vote the questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill 322 if you're in
favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
my bad I always wondered what happened
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote while you were
attending to the state of the
vote 218 in the affirmative and 106 very
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following en titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1028
establishing a commission commission to
study the delivery of Behavioral crisis
services to individuals with mental
illness we have an impairment primarily
caused by intellectual disability
representative Wayne McDonald moves at
the house Concur and is recognized speak
thank you Mr
Speaker the um the bill originally just
basically um revise the definition of
mental illness for purposes of the
Mental Health Services System uh to
remove the exclusion of intellectual
disability and provide that an
individual shall not be deemed
ineligible for mental health services
due to a co-occurrence of mental illness
and intellectual disability what the
Senate did is replaced that all the
entire Bill and to create a commission
to study the delivery of Behavioral
crisis services to individuals with
mental illness not primarily due to
intellectual disability we ask that you
please
concur the questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill 1028 you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the Motions adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following en titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as concurrence of the house house
bill
BAU Representatives Wayne McDonald and
janigian move that the house concur
representative Wayne McDonald's
speak thank you Mr
Speaker um taste Banu generously
bequeathed uh much of his estate his
estate
basically formerly of nashor and he uh
when he be made the requ a request he
asked that it be appropriated to the
refugee Children's resettlement Fund
established under RSA 161 colon
2C uh the um the Department of Health
and Human Services wasn't sure exactly
how to apply that and Refugee
resettlement is usually federally funded
so they uh they weren't sure what to do
with it we formed a subcommittee in the
health and human services and elderly
Affairs committee and the subcommittee
that we formed decided to appropriate uh
the or to assign the funds to three
different uh programs one was a cent
Care Alliance of New Hampshire The
International Institute of New England
of Manchester and RCA kids of Manchester
we decided to assign it to all three of
those equally 1/3 one3 and one3 the
Senate decided to change that
appropriation and make it instead 1/3
1/3 1/3 40% 40 % and 20% it's a
concurrence questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill 1303 you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
all those pose nay the eyes have it and
the Motions adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate occurs in the H
excuse me the Senate URS with the house
and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the pass of
wish Amendment the Senate ask occurrence
of the house house bill
1568 relative to reimbursement for
ambulance services under the State
Medicaid plan and making an
appropriation
therefore represent Wayne McDonald moves
at the house concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker what happened
with this bill basically the house
passed it 237 to
136 it went over to the Senate and they
basically adopted our language and they
had an originally built SB 409 and it
came back essentially with them having
adopted Ed the house position uh since
it's basically opposition I would ask
that we
concur questions on the motion to Concur
and ask Bill 1568 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the Motions adopted the chair recognizes
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as the concurrence of the house
house bill 16 197 relative to expanded
protections representative Wayne
McDonald moves that the house
concur representative peternell is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker this I will
be very brief honorable colleagues over
lunch I spoke with new Mexico Senator
David
gayos they attempted similar legislation
last year and another attempt will be
voted on again this July the impetus for
the similar New Mexico bill was a baby
who had been discovered in a dumpster
the baby's mother bagged the child put
it in a trash bag and covered it with
and it was tossed into the dumpster and
covered with more trash a dumpster diver
heard the infant cry and called the the
police that baby is still alive today
how much more Humane would it have been
for that baby to be deposited in an
infant safety device it is a miracle
that that baby was discovered at all let
alone recovered alive if we continue to
deter and block parents from
surrendering their babies
alive babies like this this one will
simply disappear we will have more
babies like the Eckersley baby in
Manchester more babies like meline
kitner and sorth who was suffocated in a
meth Den not one opponent of the
exclusionary rule will answer the
question of what will
happen to the next doofan baby when his
parents cannot safely surrender
him the answer is really
unspeakable infants are the most
vulnerable people in our society if we
continue to hunt down and prosecute
parents who use our safe havens these
babies cannot get up and go to another
state with better safe haven laws all of
us in this room are their last and only
line of defense an exclusionary rule is
the only way to allow this our safe
haven law to work other states are
coming to grips with the same issue and
New Mexico is looking to New Hampshire
to lead the way in protecting the mother
in order to protect the infant please
support the motion to concur on House
Bill
16007 representative Wayne McDonald's
Speaker I'm just going to try to address
a number of the questions and concerns
that have been expressed about hp67
during its journey through the house and
the Senate uh as as as it's been
indicated House Bill 16007 expand Safe
Haven surrender protections for infants
by number one allowing the use of an
infant safety device for surrender of a
child number two expanding the age from
up to seven days from up to seven days
to up to 61 days of age and number three
clarifying protections for the
surrendering individual to preclude any
using any information directly gained
from the act of the a child surrender to
be used as evidence of a crime or
wrongdoing questions been asked why is
such a bill needed our current
legislation is two decades old and needs
to be updated specifically to expand the
age limit in line with other states and
to promote the anonymous surrender of
children to ensure their highest and
best chance of survival now the question
is does this method of surrender
actually save lives and the answer is
yes while it is difficult to know how
many because of a lack of official
statistics and confidentiality rules
there have been some notable examples
that were covered in local and National
media what we do know is that by
reinforcing the protections and widening
eligibility criteria even more children
would likely be saved now the question
why aren't we letting criminals Go free
by not investigating and pursuing
prosecution for wrongdoing and I know
this is a huge concern and probably the
biggest this is a matter of weighing a
child's life against the single Avenue
of evidence this concept is routinely
applied in the law to ensure needed
protections are in place yes it is a tra
off but the life of a child is well
worth it we only need to look at the
case of Danielle Doan an abusive mother
in New Hampshire who was arrested as a
result of a child surrender to
understand the value of this
exclusionary rule she used the safe
haven law because she thought she could
do it anonymously the resulting
prosecutions and a very different
message that could very well disway the
next ofan a unless we act to protect
these
children notably the New Hampshire
associ assciation of criminal defense
attorneys supports the exclusionary
provision as an effective harm reduction
measure they have also clarify the
exclusionary provision does not preclude
prosecution what it does is restrict
prosecutors from using the specific
Avenue for evidence and requires them to
use other evidentiary sources and tools
in their February 29th letter to the
house Health and Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee the
association stated and I quote the safe
haven exclusionary rule proposed here is
similar to the drug overdose Good
Samaritan law that was enacted in
2015 that protects both the victim of an
overdose and a witness who requests
medical assistance the goal of the
exclusionary rule proposed in hb67 is
simple to incentivize Medical Care and
intervention rather than prosecution
harm reduction is sound Humane public
policy end quote
another question is the surrender
process safe previously our stfe our
safe haven law allowed only for direct
surrender to an individual by
introducing the option of an infant
safety device sometimes called a baby
box parents may be encouraged by the
extra layer of anonymity the infant
safety device is a rigorously tested
mechanism that is designed specifically
to safely accept delivery of a child is
located in inside a facility that is
staffed 24 hours a day such as a fire
station or a hospital and it's equipped
with an alarm that promptly notifies
Personnel that a child has been
surrendered these devices have been in
use across the country since 2016 with
no issues no infant safety device in any
state in America has ever harmed a child
in any way and finally what is the
threat pictured for children in New
Hampshire each year in New Hampshire
there are are thousands of cases related
to child abuse or neglect and these are
just a percentage of the true picture
many of these cases are fueled by drug
and alcohol abuse New Hampshire ranks
among the highest in both drug and
alcohol use children are often the
Forgotten victims many living in
seriously degraded and neglectful
circumstances giving parents a wider
window and removing every potential
barrier to surrendering unwanted
children could provide desperately
needed safety and protection for
children unable to speak or care for
themselves and for this reason we ask
that you
concur representative Seth Kings
recommendation one moment
please representative McDonald does a
member yield for a question yes the
thank you representative um we have
heard that uh there is no other state in
the nation that has a language such as
in the Senate Amendment for the
exclusionary rule as you put it do you
case I think at least one reason for
that is the fact that no other state has
used police to investigate and prosecute
a parent surrendering a baby but we have
in New Hampshire and this is the reason
we need to concur with the Senate we
need to encourage parents in crisis to
safely surrender their baby and this can
literally save
lives sorry about that representative
King you're
up thank you Mr Speaker esteemed
colleagues uh a lot of time has already
been spent on trying to sell us on the
baby box idea uh we're already sold on
the baby box idea when this came before
us a couple months ago split the bill in
two we voted on the baby box 373 to1 uh
overwhelmingly support it's the
exclusionary role that was extremely
divisive uh we killed it here I spoke
before the Judiciary Committee on the
other body uh against the adding the
exclusionary rule we had uh
representatives from the Departments of
Health and Human Services and Justice
speaking against adding the exclusionary
rule unfortunately it was added in a
strictly partisan manner
uh and then when it went before the
entire body it was also passed on in a
strictly partisan manner so you might be
asking Seth why are you going against
your party on this issue and I would say
I'm not going against my party on this
issue I'm standing with all of the other
Republicans around the country who have
passed Safe Haven laws and did not add
an exclusionary rule okay there are 2 22
states that have passed the safe the
safe haven boxes all right we've got a
few blue States like like Maryland and
New Mexico we've got some purple States
like Maine and Montana but the
overwhelming majority of them are deep
red States we're talking Alabama
Missouri Mississippi Arkansas okay the
Republicans in those States could have
easily passed an exclusionary rule
without any help from the Democrats so
we can't blame the Democrats on killing
the exclusionary rule the Republicans
around the country have decided that
they did not need to add an exclusionary
rule in order to get the benefits of the
baby boxes okay it's the New Hampshire
Republicans that have decided to add
this language much to my sugrin because
I also supported the baby box idea so
what I recommend is this year we do not
concur in six months the sponsors of the
bill can bring back the baby box Bill
hopefully they will not include the that
extra part of the exclusionary rule and
it'll sail through both bodies get
signed in the corner office and we can
all go our merry way but but this
exclusionary rule is just it's just way
too far uh I cannot support and I know
there are many New Hampshire citizens
who would feel very uncomfortable about
giving deao immunity to Baby rapists so
please vote to not concur thank you does
the member yield for a question member
does not yield representative Mark
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker and
I will keep my remarks only on the
subject of the exclusionary rule
consider two
parallels a police officer believes in a
particular dwelling there are items
proving the bad guy is a bad guy so the
police officer goes in there takes those
items the judge throws them out because
there was no
warrant Well we'd like to pin it on the
bad guy but I think we realize the
sanctity of our homes from unwarranted
police
invasion overrules this I think it's a
freedom issue and secondly a court case
in this state a judge demanded a physici
violate the doctor patient
confidentiality to obtain needed
information and if you like me are a fan
of reading through Rules of Evidence
you'll discover in 502 in the
footnote it was reversed upon appeal
because the state had not done due
diligence to get the information they
needed in ways other than violating Dr
patient
confidentiality and again to me this is
a freedom issue so what we have is the
greater good of that baby being spared
over one way of pinning things on the
bad guys things that the States state
can do with a rigorous policing action
so please vote Yes vote vote green vote
for the
babies the questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill
16007 I hear a division vote
requested who requested the roll
call requested who requested ites Perez
representative Christine Perez request a
roll call it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
while you're finding your seats a
reminder that if you're not at your seat
you can't second anything so like save
the energy and don't wave your arms when
you're walking down the aisle it doesn't
you
seats now is the time for all good
members to be in their seats except the
two doing
P questions on the motion to Concur and
House Bill 16007 representative Weber is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
parents May safely surrender a baby
today in a number of different
ways and if I know that I do not want to
potentially allow 61 days of child abuse
and then giving a get out of jail free
pass to that abuser would I now vote no
on the incur
motion representative lind's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that parents to willing to leave their
babies with a stranger or in a box are
very likely involved in criminal
activity against their child and if I
know that right now such parents who use
our safe haven law can expect to be
arrested as a result of surrendering
their baby and if I know that unless
this changes there is no real incentive
to use the safe haven law and if I know
that hp67 grants use immunity only and
does not Grant what's called
transactional immunity that is somebody
that surrenders their baby can still be
prosecuted if they've if they've abused
the child based on evidence independent
of the surrender um and finally if I
know that forcing a violent abusive
parent to keep his or her baby
uh will will result in very bad outcomes
for the child then would I now press the
green button to pass this life saving
Bill thank
you questions on the motion to Concur
and house bill 16007 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will ATT
of the state of the
vote 185 in the affirmative 174 in the
negative the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate URS with
the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
and the excuse me with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
URS to the house house bill 16009
relative to the commission on the
primary care Workforce and the State
Office of rural health for what reason
does a member rise to make a motion say
State your motion I motion that we print
the remarks of the last debate in the
permanent
Journal we are
on the motion to concur on House Bill
1609 representative Wayne McDonald moves
speak thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1609 is relative to
the commission on the primary care
Workforce on the State Office of rural
Health the changes that the Senate made
unlike some of the bills we've
considered today were pretty minor they
changed the membership agency from the
New England Primary Care Alliance to the
direct Primary Care Frontier and we ask
your
concurrence the question is on the
motion to concur on House Bill 16009 you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I all those oppos nay the eyes
have it and the motion's adopted
hello hello Mr Speaker may I make a
motion yes I move that we print the
remarks from house bill 16007 in the
permanent journal without
printed chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following titled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked it Ur to the
house house bill 1712 renewing the
committee to study non-pharmacological
treatment options for patients with
chronic pain Wayne mdon representative
Wayne McDonald moves at the house Concur
and is recognized to speak thank you Mr
Speaker uh as the clerk stated this HB
1712 renews the committee to study
non-pharmacological treatment options
for patients with chronic pain this was
another minor change by the Senate the
Senate version extends the committee
Sunset to
2025 by adding the not the quote
notwithstanding 14 colon 49 unquote
Clause we ask you
curement the questions on the motion to
concurent House Bill 1712 you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those post nay eyes haveit and the
Motions adopted the chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate URS of the house and
the passage of the following title bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1220 abolishing
the collection of racial and educational
data for use in a marital application
worksheet and relative to the
expectation of privacy
representative Lynn moves at the house
concurrent is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1220 uh I moved to concur as it as the
bill left this house it eliminated the
collection of racial and educational
data for use in marital applications the
Senate did not change this part of the
bill but it added to the bill language
amending the Privacy Bill uh we passed
earlier this year that is Senate Bill
255 that bill as it passed both bodies
uh was signed into law uh as it was
signed into law required the Secretary
of State to establish certain standards
for privacy notices and for the methods
by which uh a consumer could exercise a
right to opt out of uh the uh Provisions
uh that would allow his his or her
private information to be sold the
Senate Amendment eliminates the role of
the Secretary of State but ads language
requiring the notice that notices be
available online on a mobile app or
other on other devices regularly used by
the consumer to interact with uh the
company that's covered by the statute
the Secretary of State wanted it to be
removed wanted to be removed from having
a role in this bill because he correctly
points out that his office has no
particular expertise in privacy matters
although the Judiciary Committee is not
thrilled with what the Senate did they
perhaps there could have been a better
job done um what would need to be
changed is not is more complicated than
could be accomplished in a committee of
conference and on balance what the
Senate did what the Senate did is
acceptable and it is particularly
important because the other aspect of
the bill dealing with the with the
elimination of of the rational and
educational uh uh collection of data in
the marriage applications is is very
important and had strong bipartisan
support from this body so for those
reasons I ask that you
concur questions on the motion to concur
in House Bill 1220 you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay eyes have it the
motion's adopted and the chair
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate has to concurrence to the house
house bill 1245 relative to release of
confidential records of a person
appointed a guardian and relative to
patient access to medical
records representative Lynn moves at the
house concur representative Nagel is
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker um
I'm only going to be addressing the uh
previously known Senate Bill 400 portion
of this bill which was amended into
1245 before I start I have a a
confession to make I'm part of the
problem I make a strong recommendation
to every one of my patients that it is
their right and their responsibility to
get a copy of their medical records and
that should be given to them at a
reasonable price I think that's
important and that's what the original
Senate Bill 400 actually said and that's
was really exciting to me and then it
got amended and that's when things
started to change so the first thing
that was done in the amendment was they
made a change that said that the
requestor was not just the patient or
their estate but was also their attorney
superficially I wasn't sure what I
thought about that but when I thought
more about it I realized that attorneys
asked for these records for all sorts of
reasons some of which are really I don't
want to use the word honorable because
they're all honorable but they're you
know interested the protecting the
patient where others of them are looking
more for personal injury things like
that and all of a sudden we realized
well that needs to be discussed a lot
more the second thing was is that they
put in a limit to how much you could
charge that third party for for that and
that number was awfully low it was like
$50 and we started thinking well maybe
that's a problem too so we at HHS
EA came to the conclusion that we really
need to sit down and discuss this that
this is not ready for prime time so we
voted 18-2 to send this to interim study
and You by Voice vote agreed with that
when it went back over to the other
whatever you want to call it on the
that thing body that thing so thank you
when I went over there they actually did
something really neat they they actually
put in the sliding scale that I
requested and I was always I was really
excited about that but they left in the
definition of the requester and they
also CA the fees for um uh the for
electronic records at $50 still and that
that seemed problematic to me so what I
did yesterday when I had nothing better
to do I I live I run a I used to own a a
very busy Medical Practice I was a
partner in it for 34 years which I gave
up to join all of you I went over yeah I
when I went over there I I decided I'm
going to spend time with the folks in
medical records because I want to find
out what they really do because you know
where I do I don't have a clue so I
spent the afternoon with them and I
found out what was involved for them to
satisfy these requests for records
number one they said the number of
record requests they get as overwhelming
I did not know that secondly the most
common requestor does come from third
parties specifically attorneys third
they need to be hippot trained before
they can even do this job because if
they make a mistake we get in trouble
fourth every page that they sent has to
be reviewed to make sure that it's
hippoc client before they press that
button send and that and then all of a
sudden I started realizing this is not a
cheap process
so then I talked to a couple practice
managers I said do you think this $50 is
enough every one of them said no and I
said well what number is enough they
said
$125 would be more reasonable and I said
well that sounds pretty cheap to me too
for the requests that are being put in
so basically at this point the reason
why I oppose the 400 section of it is we
really need to sit down and decide what
that attorney part of the requestor
means should it be considered as
separate legisl
or should it be part of this process and
secondly we really need to seriously
look down and see what that dollar
amount was until those things are done I
really don't think this this bill is
ready for prime time and therefore I ask
you to not concur thank
you representative Linds recognized to
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker uh
colleagues just for let me just address
what the just very briefly the non sort
of in dispute part of this bill um that
was the original bill that came out of
the house it it basically extends
further rights to somebody that's
subject to a a guardianship that is the
ward and it basically says that the ward
is entitled to get his or her own uh
records including medical records unless
a court has specifically said that that
would not be in the best interest of the
ward right now now under the law that is
not it award does not have that right
and it's and and uh we said as we sent
this bill to the Senate that they should
have with regard to the issue of
generally the Avail being able to get
medical records which the prior speaker
talked about I would agree with
everything the prior speaker said if it
weren't for one thing which I think is
critically important and that is under
federal law under Hippa if you are the
patient you can get all your records all
your medical records including all the
work that has to be done in gathering
that for zero for free you are entitled
to get all your records for free and so
the problem that I have with this whole
and the reason that I support what the
Senate has done
is if you can get all your records for
free and if you have to authorize you
the person who's you're the patient
anyone else including your attorney to
be able to get the records on your
behalf why is there any reason I I think
an argument could be made why is there
any reason why your agent gets charged
at all for those records if you under
federal law are entitled to get them for
free but I'll put that aside let's
assume that there's some maybe there's
some reason for allowing some charge it
seems to me that the that the charge
that the charges that the Senate has
allowed in in its proposal which are
relatively nominal I they're not not a
great deal of money makes perfect sense
given that if the patient himself or
herself wants the records there's no
charge at all what I have to say
honestly the flavor that you get when
you if you think about this carefully is
that you know if it's if it's the
patient that wants to get their records
then there's no problem because the
patient you know is sort of excuse my
language but he's sort of fat dumb and
happy we don't really have to worry
about the patient but if the patient is
smart enough to get a lawyer and maybe
the law you know there's a concern that
somehow there might be a lawsuit then
it's okay to discourage that by charging
that doesn't make sense to me it just
seems to me it's unfair and and the
Senate what the Senate has done will
amarate that to a great extent so that's
why I uh move to Concur and I ask you to
support what the Senate has done thank
you the questions on the motion to
concur on House Bill
1245 a division's been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
the question is on the motion to concur
on House Bill 1245 this is a division
vote no no no yeah we're in the voting
mode we're in the voting
mode never argue with the Sergeant at
Arms what are you doing no never argue
ever questions on the motion to concur
on House Bill 1245 this is a division
vote representative Merchant is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry and
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
federal Hippa law guarantees that a
patient can get their own medical record
for a nominal fee not to exceed
$6.50 and if I know that the federal
Hippa law leads it up to the
states to decide what
fees can be charged by Third parties
requesting a patient's medical
record and if I know the body Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs
committee spent a lot of time trying to
find a reasonable Fair cap to apply to
the plaintiff's
attorneys We R out of
time and if I know this body approved on
consent calendar the committee
recommendation of interim study on a
Voice vote just last week and if I know
the Senate added House Bill
1265 would simply shift cost to other
requesters and medical providers and not
come out of settlement fees from the
plaintiff's
attorneys then Mr Speaker would I now
press the red
button to make another motion thank you
representative Lind recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
if I know that what the Senate did here
is really to is really a matter of
fairness for the very reasons I stated
before dealing with the the ability of
the patient himself to get the records
for free or for
$66.50 then would I support the the
Senate's uh uh view of of doing what's
right and what's fair by pressing the
green
button the questions on the motion to
concur in House Bill 1245 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 182 in
the affirmative 175 in the negative the
chair recognized clerk for further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs with the house in the passage of
the following titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked concurrence of the house
house bill 1432 relative to prohibiting
certain uses of deep fakes and creating
action representative Lyn moves that we
Concur and is recognize the
speaker thank you colleagues um the uh
thank you Mr speaker colleagues uh the
Senate made a very very minor and
non-substantive change in language uh to
this bill uh which creates uh Civil
Right of action and criminal penalties
for uh use of artificial intelligence to
create deep fakes um the our committee
was perfect was fine with the language
and more importantly we ran it by our
resident Guru on uh artificial
intelligence the representative from
Lebanon and he also agreed so for that
reason I ask you to concur
please the motion before us is concur on
House Bill 1432 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it the motion
is adopted chair recognize the clerk for
a further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate occurs of
the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with Amendment
passage of which amendment the Senate as
the concurrence of the house house bill
1589 establishing a veterans treatment
Court
pres of Lyn and wer move that we Concur
and recognize chair recognize
representative ly to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh colleagues
the this is the veterans court Bill the
uh the Senate made very minor changes in
in terms of uh uh Chang some language
from uh to to make it clear that the
chief Jus that duties that were assigned
to the judicial branch it's the Chief
Justice or his design that will perform
those duties uh the other thing other
thing that the Senate did is they
extended the effective date of this bill
from January of 2025 to July of 2025 and
so since that will be in the next bium
they took they they took out the any
appropriate I think there was
$163,000 appropriation in as it came out
of the house the Senate took that out by
extending it just to the next bium other
than that the changes are are are
helpful and so I ask you to
concur motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1589 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it the motion
is adopted chair recogniz the cler for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1080 relative to
the legislative youth advisory Council
we representative Hill moves that we
motion thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
we passed this bill on consent earlier
this year the other body accepted it for
the most part
wholeheartedly and made a couple of
minor changes um for the example we
suggested at least temporarily narrowing
the statutory committees the council
would work with the other body preferred
to add the phrase primary focus instead
of just our word Focus which gives the
members more latitude in finding
legislation they find interesting in
general we have no objections to the
concur the motion before is to ur on
House Bill 1080 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate URS with the house
and the passage of the following entitle
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 1388
relative to ethical standards for
members of the general court Mur
representative Hill moves that we
concur on House Bill 1388 chair
H thank you Mr
Speaker the bill before you has been
attempted in this house multiple times
over the past couple of years this is
relative to when a legislator should
recuse themselves on
legislation now I I there are people in
this chamber potentially and I know
there were former members of the House
and Senate who may have violated our
current ethics rules and while I
potentially disagree with those members
on the subject matter I do believe they
have a right to talk to to discuss to
participate in the
legislation our ethics guidelines today
are very clear and I want to read a a
couple of sections of this it defines
conflict of interest is the condition in
which a legislator has a special
interest in any matter and could
directly or indirectly affect the
influence and performance of that
legislator's
activities it also defines the purpose
of this this ethics guidelines
legislators shall treat their office as
a public trust using only powers and
resources of the public office to
advance public interest and not to
attain personal benefits or to pursue
any other private interest incompatible
the bill before you doesn't prohibit
participation it doesn't it doesn't stop
at the mere thing of preventing filing
of a
bill preventing voting on a bill this
goes much further and the issue with
this is it's going to handcuff our
legislators in their ability to
represent their
constituents let me give you a couple of
examples there's some doctors in here
they may have small medical
practices they meet the
exclusionary section of this proposed
bill they are in fact renumerated
presumably if they're a small business
owner they want to actually get a
paycheck they hold the position to
exercise substantial influence over the
organization and if that organization or
that office has ever lobbied testified
or otherwise attempted to influence the
outcome of official legislative activity
they now are triggered from Full
recusal in partic in in participation
not just voting on drafting a bunch of
other things this means they can't even
be part of the discussion about whether
the bill is a good idea or not even
though they have the technical expertise
to weigh in on the subject matter now
this applies to people who have
insurance companies this applies to
doctors this applies to Engineers this
applies to everybody who is a tech
technical expert who owns a small
company there is an issue I agree we
need to fix our ethics guidelines this
goes a step too
far what the Senate did when they or the
me the body behind us did when they
amended the bill made it the made the
solution worse than the problem what we
should do is send it to a committee of
conference and try and clean up the
beginning of page two relative to when
does a legislator have to recuse them M
themselves and step away from any
participation I would ask that you would
oppose the the concur motion and support
me on a non-c concur ask for a committee
of conference thank
Hill thank you Mr Speaker um two ethics
bills calling for recusal of legislators
from legislative activities when they
experience the conflict of interest were
addressed in legislative Administration
this year both were extensively
scrutinized by our own legislative
Ethics Committee and both were
unanimously passed by our committee and
placed on the consent calender we are
here today because the body on the other
side of the wall amended the house bill
we sent them by merging the language of
those and and the subject matter of
those two bills and they made the
effective date January 1st
2025 please affirm the recommendation of
concur the motion before us is to concur
on House Bill 1388 a division has been
called for members take your seats this
do
the motion be house will be in order the
motion before us is concur on House Bill
1388 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognized representative whole
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that legislators are already prohibited
from our guidelines in introducing
legislation testifying before a
legislative committee voting in a
committee or voting on the house floor
when they have a defined conflict of
interest if I know that they have to
announce that conflict of interest if it
meets the ethics
guidelines if I further know that this
bill will handcuff future legislators
from being available to express talk
about or weigh in with their technical
expertise would I vote against the
concur motion so I can another motion
could be made thank you chair recognized
Cory thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that our bipartisan Ethics
Committee has been very involved for the
last three years in helping to craft
this legislation and very much welcome
our passing the emerged Bill and finally
Mr Speaker if I know our citizen
legislators need to be continually
concerned with the topic of conflicts of
interest and the implications and
appearance to the public of their
legislative actions when these conflicts
exist
or appear to exist would I now support
the committee recommendation of Concur
and push the green button thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is to curent
House Bill 1388 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members present and opportunity to
chair and I clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate conures of
the house in the passage of the
following entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked to concur the house house
abatements representative Len T turot
moves that we Concur and is recognized
to speak to his
motion thank you Mr
Speaker he 202 the Senate added an
amendment U meant to clarify an existing
RSA regarding the valuation of
telecommunication polls in uh 2016 an
RSA had thought to been made to make the
issue 100% clear but a lawsuit in the
town of Meredith just a few years ago
ago proved that to be
incorrect hopefully the amended language
should once and for all put that issue
to bed by adding the words without
applying an equalization rate to the RSA
I ask that you
concur the motion will be for us to
concur on house B 202 are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
those oppose nay eyes have it motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 1055 relative to
the property tax exemption for
resident Len tart M we concur when is
recognized to speak to his motion thank
you Mr Speaker about the easiest uh
Amendment I've ever seen this one I'm
asking you to concur on uh the in HB
1055 the word assessors was removed from
the bill and this was to prevent the uh
potential conflict between the set
Selectmen and the assessors in the
municipalities with Selectmen so we ask
that you concur the motion before ask is
to concur on House Bill 1055 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for a further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate URS of the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 1187 relative to prohibiting lease
agreements of equipment for building or
facility
improvements representa L tur moves that
we Concur and is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker uh hp1 uh 887 again
we ask that you concur it uh the bill
deals with equipment lease statutes when
it went over to the Senate uh the the
renewable energy industry had concerns
with it although those concerns were
really uh incorrect however to assuage
those concerns they actually drafted
duplicate language uh and added uh
couple of lines that would assu the
renewable energy industry so what will
happen is the first paragraph will go
into effect 60 days after passage three
years from now July 1 that will drop off
and the original language of HB 1187
will be in place so we do ask that you
concur on that motion before us is to
concur on House Bill 1187 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppos nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs to the
house and the passage of the following
title bill with Amendment the passage of
which amendment the Senate asked a
concurrence of the house house bill
1103 relative to revising the penalties
act representative rulu moves that we
speak thank you Mr speaker uh this is a
a
a uh only one sentence change it's
actually a change uh in the in the uh
from the house from the house bill to
the Senate Bill the the original law
says persons violating the provisions of
this chapter and damaging the public
Waterway who after notification by the
department failed to make a good faith
effort at remediation and restoration
shall be subject to the following and
then they list a whole bunch of uh
penalties the
house took a took that sentence and and
actually changed it to persons violating
the provisions of this chapter shall be
subject to the following in the list of
penalties the Senate added some language
back which actually improves the bill
and it it says persons violating the
provisions of this chapter who fail to
restore the site to meet the applicable
standards of this chapter within one
year of receiving the notification of a
violation of the department shall be
subject to the following and again
that's the the uh the the
penalties uh it was we did bring this to
the poll the committee committee was uh
uh those who replied back were 100% for
it this is a uh an improvement on the
bill so please concur the motion before
is to concur on House Bill 1103 FN are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as to concurrence of the house
house bill 1121 relative to creating
certain Wetlands permit exemptions after
event repr sen vulo moves at week and
speak thank you Mr Speaker this is the
the bill is actually a subparagraph that
uh uh to the Excavating and dredging
permit
uh there is a the an inclusion of a the
House Bill H is removal of the Woody
debris and blockages from the channels
of water courses from the culverts or
Bridges by the owner of said structure
by the property owner is allowed without
a permit provide provide is allowed
without per permit provided sediment
disturbance is minimized and the work
results in no new permanent impacts to
the bed of the water course the Senate
added of uh to that section A few few
bits of language uh after when it says
removal of Woody debris and blockages
the Senate added after a natural
disaster or flooding event and a the
also the Senate added provided
mechanized equipment does not enter the
water course this is an improvement the
bill uh the uh changes were uh approved
I discussed it with the uh person with
the prime
sponsor she approves it is an
approvement will uh we could move to
concur the motion before us to concur on
House Bill 1121 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recogniz the clerk for
for the Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following en titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment Senate
asked concurrence of the house house
bill 1554 relative to certified covert
maintainer program reporting and
requiring the commissioner of the
Department of enironmental Services to
regulate The Cutting of Native Native
aquatic vegetation on submerged lands
and public Waters or certain public
owned water bodies and establishing rule
repr sentive manulo moves that we Concur
speak thank you Mr Speaker the uh change
that occurred in the Senate is uh only
uh is is is in one
sentence uh in the in in this bill the
sentence uh the house uh version of the
sentences the commissioner shall
regulate The Cutting of native aquatic
vet vegetation on submerged lands in
Lakes subject to this
chapter the Improvement uh that the and
it is an improvement that the Senate uh
added to the uh to the bill uh the
commissioner shall regulate The Cutting
of native aquatic vegetation on
submerged lands in public Waters or
public owned water bodies regulated
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the pass
of which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 609
relative to the site evaluation
sighting represent V moves that we
speak thank you Mr Speaker house Bill
609 is undoubtedly the most important
energy related bill that we have heard
this bium it makes significant changes
in combination with
hb281 and Senate Bill
451 to the operation of the site
evaluation committee collectively these
changes will make the sighting of energy
projects in the future less expensive
and will allow them to happen more
quickly
House Bill 609 the Senate did make some
changes but they were refinements to an
already good bill that make it even
better they added Preamble references to
the fish to quote Fish and Wildlife
Resources of the state and to quote
offshore they changed a reference to
batteries from megawatt hours to
megawatts they changed the
administrative attachment of the site EV
value ation committee from the
Department of energy to the Public
Utilities
Commission they added new application
language that reads and I quote describe
in reasonable detail the impact of each
major part of the proposed facility on
existing land and offshore uses
unquote they add a reference to the need
for offshore projects to comply with the
federal coastal zone management
act they added new language to exempt
any application filed prior to the date
of the adoption of this statute from
having to
reapply and finally they change the
effective date to upon passage rather
than 60 days after passage these are all
very good refinements to an already good
bill and I urge you all to concur with
the motion before us is concur on House
Bill 69 FN are you ready for the
question all those who here say I iOS n
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
chair recogniz clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following title bill Amendment the and
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked concurrence the house house
bill 1078 relative to the Department to
sty safety establishing a repository of
state pres V moves that we Concur and is
recognized to speak thank you again Mr
Speaker House Bill
1078 originally asked the department of
safety to do a study to discover how to
close gaps in the communication coverage
of
Safety Services radio communication
coverage the Senate took a different
approach and made a significant change
to the bill instead of asking the
department of safety to study this
question they created language to
require that the department create maps
to identify the locations of all
Municipal County and state government
Radio Systems throughout the state and
make those Maps available as needed so
communities counties and the state
itself could develop ways to fill those
gaps and make communication more
effective this is a significant
Improvement to the bill and we ask for
your
concurrence the the motion before us is
to ur on House Bill
1078 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos nay
the eyes haven't and the committee
report is the report is adopted yeah I
recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs of the house and the passage of
the following titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked concurrence of the house
house bill 1431 relative to utility
planning representative V moves that we
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker
again this bill passed by the house
added new language to statute to require
utilities to perform every 5 years a
plan to do integrated distribution
planning the Senate made a few changes
they removed the altered language of RSA
378 colon 37 from the original
bill they changed the start date for
these five-year plans to within five
years rather than start
immediately they added the words coste
effective before benefits in plan
forecasts they changed four weeks to 12
weeks for amending rejected plans and
they fixed a few language problems
without changing any
meaning all these changes we consider to
be improvements to the bill and we ask
for your
concurrence motion before us to concur
on House Bill 1431 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it the motion
is adopted chair recogniz the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
of amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1465 relative to
studies of nuclear energy Technologies
and renaming the office of offshore wind
industry
development representative V and wer
move that we can C representative V is
uh ready to speak thank you Mr Speaker
the Senate made some excellent changes
to this bill as well the bill that we
sent them renamed the office of offshore
wind industry development to the office
of energy
Innovation but the other body didn't
like that name so they changed it to
office of offshore wind industry
development and
energy
Innovation they also fixed a reference
within the bill and they changed the
effective date to upon passage these are
all good changes and we ask for your
concurrence the motion before us is to
concur on House Bill 1465 FN are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say i i fay the eyes have it and
chair recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following title bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill
1499 establishing a committee to study
the civilian clean energy Community
resilience and Conservation Corps and
establishing a committee to style the
act representative V we we Concur and is
motion thank you Mr Speaker the SP
Senate the body the body on the other
side of the wall I should say made no
changes to the substance of the bill we
sent to them however they did
add a study committee bill of their own
a study committee to study the child
protection
act the child protection act study
committee has to issue a report of its
findings by November 1st of
2024 I spoke with the chair of Child and
Family Services here in the
house and we discussed the bill and
decided it was an innocuous uh and
probably well- needed bill so I'm
willing to concur with this
motion the motion before us to concur in
House Bill 1499 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppose
nay eyes have it and the motion is
adopted okay I recognize the clerk for
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asked
concurrence the house house bill 1600
establishing a committee to study the
aggregation of electric customers by
counties representative V moves that we
concur chair recognized representative
Corman
thank you Mr Speaker I am the prime
sponsor of this bill and I would much
rather prefer to see a committee of
conference for this bill because the
other body completely changed the bill
the bill was requested by the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire just to
remind everybody the community power
Coalition provides a market-based
approach to our electric supply and it
reduces costs for Granite State
customers the bill that we sent allows
Community power to use en the member
will
suspend the noise in the chamber is
getting to be
deafening a member has a right to be
heard if you need to take have a
conversation take it out in the back
room remember may continue thank you
very much Mr Speaker I appreciate that
the bill that we sent excuse me the bill
that we sent allows Community power to
use energy that's created locally to
lower prices for Community power
customers they can already do this for
power that is at most one megawatt and
all this bill does is increases the
range to up to 5 megawatts there is no
cost shift to utility rate payers again
no cost shift to utility rate payers it
helps Community power we want to help
Community power we want to remove
roadblocks and there are several
projects ready to go right now and just
also to remind you community power is
already serving towns representing about
35% of the state's population uh
including the town of eping from which
my good friend uh uh is the
representative now what did the other
body do they turned this bill into a
committee
to study Community power so I believe we
should non-c Concur and request a
committee of conference and actually the
other body actually wants us to do this
let me
explain during the hearing in the house
science technology and energy committee
the department of energy testified that
they were neutral on this
bill and it passed our committee
unanimously and passed this body on
consent then it went over to the other
body where the energy and natural
resources committee heard it and the
department of energy again testified
that they were neutral on the
bill weeks later just before the energy
and natural resources Committee of the
other body was about to exec the bill
the department of energy sent a letter
to the committee
chair changing its position
opposing the
bill the letter listed some concerns and
the community power Coalition responded
in detail to every one of those concerns
in
detail the letter also raised unintended
consequences Mr
Speaker any bill could have unintended
consequences but you got to say what
they are otherwise
frankly you're just blowing
smoke so what happened was that the
president of the other body who is a
co-sponsor of this bill and would like
to see it get through offered an
amendment to create the study commission
why would he do that was to buy time for
further negotiation with the Department
of energy which so far has really been
unwilling to engage with the community
power Coalition so this amendment that
we are being asked to concur with is
merely a placeholder it is there just to
resolve differences in the committee of
conference the president of the other
body wants this bill he wants a
committee of conference to get us there
I would like the same we do not need a
study committee to study Community power
it's already happening we don't need to
study it so I ask you to please vote
against the concur motion with this
placeholder Amendment so that we can
have a motion to non-c Concur and
request a committee of conference and Mr
Speaker I request a division vote do a
member yield the questions I do not
member does not yield chair recognize
representative
Speaker as my esteemed colleague from
Lebanon just pointed out
out during the Committee hearing on this
bill the department of energy said that
they were neutral on the policy aspect
of the
bill but they did point out that they
had some concerns about
it they were unable to articulate those
concerns before the committee so we
passed the bill thinking that they were
okay with it when the bill got to the
Senate they
once again testified that they were
neutral on the
policy but that they had some concerns
with it when they were pressed to
express those concerns they eventually
sent a letter to Senate
enr and they asked some serious
questions questions like who will ensure
and how will it be determined that the
group load will be greater than the
community supplier what happens if it
isn't what will the registration process
and requirements look like for Community
suppliers and how will these entities be
monitored to ensure requirements are
being
met what will be the oversight mechanism
to ensure Community suppliers are in
ongoing compliance with applicable
statutes and pu rules will this
oversight require involvement from the
community aggregator the department and
the distribution
utility will community the aggregators
in towns served by more than one
distribution utility complicate
oversight who will provide oversight to
ensure the statute is being applied
consistently across Community
aggregations the department also
indicated that time is needed to Think
Through the unintended consequence
scenarios to ensure that there are guard
rails in place these consequences may
leave the department and the legislature
to deal to deal with some unresolved
issues and finally they pointed out that
issues
concerning net metering are under
consideration in a department of energy
docket
23063 and the question of the reduction
of wholesale load
obligations both still need to be
practice now these
concerns that the department has
certainly are sufficient to Warrant a
study
committee so the Senate decided that
that was an effective way to deal with
uncertainties none of us is real happy
with creating a study committee in the
second year of a bium there's not much
time to actually produce much of a study
but in this particular case I think a
study is warranted before we move
forward so I would ask you to concur
with our motion or to agree with our
motion to concur with the Senate changes
to
hb600 thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before is to concur on House Bill 1600 a
division has been recall has been called
for it members take your seats this will
vote
the motion before us is concur on House
Bill
1600 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognize representative Corman
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill helps Community power which serves
about 35% of the state's population is
the second largest supplier of power in
the state offers electric rates lower
than eversource Unitil Liberty Utilities
and the New Hampshire Electric Co-op has
already saved rate payers $14 million
compared with the crisis
uh that utilities
charge and if I know that the amendment
that we are being asked to concur with
was proposed by the president of the
other body to get us to a committee of
conference and finally if I know that
every one of the points raised by the
department of energy that my friend from
eping listed was responded to in detail
by the community power Coalition would I
then press the red button to get us to
another motion thank you to recognize
represent VES for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that in a Public Communication
to the legislature the department of
energy identified seven major questions
that need to be resolved before this
bill can move
forward and if I know that the Senate
established a study commit committee to
deal with these seven major issues would
I press the green button to concur with
this legislation thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is to ur on House
Bill 1600 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposal press the red
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 169 voting a 174 voting aay the
motion
fails for what reason is member rise Mr
Speaker I move to non-c Concur and
former Committee of
conference the motion is to non-c concur
in a committee of conference are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I may the eyes have it and
the motion
passes on behalf of
the house the chair appoints
McGee chair Rec and Isa clerk for a
further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
titled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
the concurrence of the house house bill
programs representative V mov we Concur
speak thank you again Mr
Speaker this bill set up a methodology
to study carbon credits
and the Senate made a change to the
preliminary to add that a preliminary
report was due in 2024 but the final
report was not due until 2025 that's a
change from the original bill in
addition they
added language that allows a landowner
agent or a foreign car Forest carbon
program administrator to notif by
municipalities of these carbon for
Forest carbon uh projects that's a
significant change but one that's
worthwhile so I ask for your approval of
this concur motion the motion be for us
to concur on House Bill 1697 FN are you
ready for the question all those in
favor to say I I suppose nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for another Senate
message Mr speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill
1567 relative to zoning Provisions
concerning family and group family child
care
uses representative Nelson moves we
speak thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon colleagues this bill passed uh
our body on consent and went over to the
other body and passed um through their
committee with an amendment and
unanimously went to a Voice vote with
the floor amendment that tweaked um that
amendment that was passed through their
committee the amendment is as follows if
all requirements of the Department of
Health and Human Services
are met but an application for a
conditional use permit is pending with
the municipality in which the homebased
child care facility is located an
applicant May begin operation during
such time until the permit is granted or
denied the committee is okay with this
amendment and the prime sponsor also is
so we con Cur I'm hoping that you also
will vote to enur as it is an important
step forward in an effort to help us
solve the child care
crisis the motion for us is concurent
House Bill 1567 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say i iose n
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate URS with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the pass of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1065 relative to
fire sprinkler requirements in
residential
buildings representative Alexander mov
that we con current is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker HB 1065 adds
an exception to the state fire code for
SP fire suppression and sprinker
sprinkler system requirements for
certain existing residential buildings
with no more than four dwelling units um
and oh okay
um and regulations that are more
stringent than the state prohibits
municipalities from enforcing
regulations that are more stringent than
the state fire code um the other body
made one change to let the State Fire
Marshall have more discretion in cases
concurrence motion is to concur on House
Bill 1065 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted okay I recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as to concurrence
the house house bill 1168 establishing a
committee to study the impact of the
disabilities repr Alexander moves that
we concurrent is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker although I'm not
typically a fan of study committees this
committee is to study the housing crisis
on people with disabilities the special
on housing heard from dozens of people
from the disability rights community at
an almost 3-hour public hearing um and
they would like time to look
specifically into this I think it's an
important bill for them um do the other
body amended the language to extend the
effective date out for the final report
I recommend
concurrence motion before is to Cur on
House Bill 11
168 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passor the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill
12:15 relative to development approvals
and appeals and allowing the town of
Hampton to discontinue a particular
property representative Alexander moves
that we concur the chair recognize
tkart thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon again I want to make it clear
that there are two parts to this bill
the original language and an amendment
that was added by the Senate which has
uh been known as now the uh Hampton
discontinua Road Amendment I'm speaking
only to the second part and that is the
new Amendment
the amendment to this uh hb1 1215 would
allow the board of Selectmen in Hampton
to discontinue a road a Town Road in the
beach area bypassing our ex our existing
laws then rent out that road for up to
99 years to some unknown private
business this is not a class six Road
like you'd find out in the woods that
they're discontinuing this is a uh a
road in the middle of the downtown
business and residential District of
Hampton Beach known as Avenue D any of
you who've been down in Hampton Beach
you know how the Avenues work they go
from Ash Ashworth AB all the way down to
Route
1A so this would bypass the normal
process where the town votes on whether
to allow such an action at either a
regular or special town meeting special
Town meetings can be called by either
the Selectmen or the town citizens and a
Butters only require 14 days notice this
is less than a couple of months it would
take to uh go through the normal process
so one has to ask why why the rush and
why a special carve out that ends up in
our rsas
permanently New Hampshire law is very
specific that town residents are the
local legislative body empowered to
discontinue roads not the Selectmen this
takes away the H the residents of
Hampton's right to vote on this issue I
want enough bill for a special project
sets a terrible precedent if this passes
we we will then see repeated and
frequent attempts to use this precedent
if you think about it this would be very
similar to or actually worse in a lot
worse than taking Land by eminent Don uh
eminent domain what about the abutters
property rights here could this be
construed as the use of eminent uh
domain by a town to benefit a private
entity or whoever that may be I want to
read you something something in 2006 New
Hampshire Senate Bill 287 was signed
into law after a US US Supreme Court
decision case that allowed a Connecticut
town to take private property for
commercial
development it was signed into law by
the governor at the time and that law
stated public use shall not include the
public benefits resulting from private
Economic Development and private
commercial Enterprise including
increased tax revenues and increased
employment and opportunities If This
Were to go through you're going to see a
large
amount several law suits that going to
be filed and it's actually going to take
longer to get through the lawsuit
process than you are to go ahead and
meeting this is about property rights of
the abuts and the town citizens this is
about this body not setting a bad
precedent that could affect many
property Property Owners throughout our
state in the future by allowing The
Taking of property by adverse
possession above all this is about
consistency versus arbitrariness I know
in our committee we try to remain
consistent no one-offs no special
dispensations placed into the
rsas I've been authorized by the uh HRA
to repeat what I said in caucus this
morning and that is the pink sheet is
incorrect it was supposed to agree with
what I'm trying to get you here and that
is vote against the motion to concur so
we can send this over to a committee
conference and remove this
added um the added Amendment from the
Senate again I'm only speaking to that
Amendment I'm not speaking to the
original language even though some
people may have something to say about
that so I'll ask you to vote red on the
motion of concur so that another motion
can be made thank you Mr Speaker J
Alexander thank you Mr Speaker um Mr
Speaker sections 1 through five provide
regulatory relief for property owners
and developers that prohibits political
subdivisions from Dem demanding items
above and beyond those enshrined in
statute or zoning ordance at the time of
the issuance of the permit um
subdivision approval are plat and sets
forth in the appeals process for those
agreed by political subdivision boards
decisions to the contrary section five
is really what we're talking about it's
about the Hampton Beach um Road it's
enabling legislation specifically
drafted to function as the equivalent of
a um rule suspension for that particular
purpose of allowing the town of Hampton
to enter into a lease agreement of one
and only one clearly identified Road
only after two public hearings are held
for the purposes of of redeveloping the
casino ballroom I don't know if you've
been there recently I think it's a great
area but I think we could use some a
little bit of economic revitalization
there um with significant fire and
safety issues into a vibrant multi-use
facility that will bring in much tax
revenue for the state and um tourism and
hopefully a lot more money and many jobs
the silver lining of this renovation
project is that the decline of Hampton
Beach has been experiencing over the
last decade will reverse and the entire
Beach area will improve in safety and
prosperity um so very important that
section 8 repeals section 6 and 7 so
it's closing the door on this rule
suspension this is a one-time suspension
of this to allow Hampton to do this
project um the people of Hampton are
asking for it and they also have
opportunity for public hearing so this
is still a local control issue thank you
please
concur the motion before us is to
concur on House Bill 1215
so turot has requested a roll call is
sufficient second representative turot
when turot has requested a roll call it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
motion before us is to concur on house
build
12:15 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that hb1
1215 now includes this puzzling
amendment that restates what the town of
Hampton's governing body and planning
board can already do and if I know that
the underlying Bill meant to alleviate
New Hampshire's acute housing shortage
will only perpetuate that shortage by
doubling from 5 to 10 years the time a
developer can be Exempted from changes
in safety codes and other Municipal
ordinances if I further know that if
after 5 years a developer has not made
significant progress then something is
going very wrong would I now press the
red button to vote non-c concur on
hb125 so that another motion may be made
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognized C
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the Hampton Beach
Casino ballroom has been an engine that
has driven economic activity on the Sea
Coast and our entire state for 125 years
and if I know that the ballroom is has
now reached the end of its useful life
and if you like me are thrilled that the
current owners of the ballroom have
committed to redevelop the property at
their own
expense and that as part of that project
the owners wish to integrate property
they own on both sides of D Street into
their
design and Mr Speaker if I know that in
order to move forward the owners of the
ballroom would like Clarity on the
disposition of D Street Street and if I
know that D Street is a 500t stretch of
roadway with very little traffic and no
abutters other other than the ballrooms
owners and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that nothing we do here today should be
interpreted as implying approval of the
proposed Redevelopment project which
will still need to be reviewed by the
appropriate local boards before it can
proceed would I now press the green
button to give the select board the
option if they wish to exercise it or
not to close that 500t roadway but only
after holding five public hearings five
five public meetings to provide the
residents of Hampton most of whom are
very excited about this project ample
opportunity to express their opinions on
the matter thank you the motion before
us is to concur on House Bill 12:15 this
a roll call vote if you're favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
[Music]
repres all members president had an
opportunity to vote househ attend to
fails representative Alexander moves at
the house non-c Concur and AED to a
committee of
conference are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it a motion for a
appointed to the committee of conference
are Alexander representative Alexander
power chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house buillt 1355 relative
to the New Hampshire National Guard
Recruitment and reenlistment incentive
program and continuing a recruitment and
retention incentive program and efforts
Transportation representative mfet moves
speak thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
to the members for the many kind
birthday wishes today as well okay uh so
HB
1355 involves an Hampshire National
Guard recruitment and reenlistment
incentive program with an accompanying
allocation which was approved by state
federal veterans committee it was
approved by the finance committee was
approved by this full house as well as
by the other body now the other body
later added language that also supported
the department of
transportation's Recruitment and
Retention efforts it provides definition
for bonuses and referral fees but it
also made clear or makes clear that any
future related requested expenditures
will require the approval of the fiscal
Committees of the general court so while
there was a fiscal note for the original
HB 1355 which was
approved uh the National Guard
recruiting incentive there is no fiscal
component to the added language from the
other body which simply seeks to support
Do's recruiting and retention efforts so
I would simply ask that my colleagues
support our concur recommendation
you the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1355 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos n the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted chair recognize the
clerk for further Sen message thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
of the house and the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked the concurrence of the
house house bill 1122 relative to lights
Vehicles restive Walsh moves we Concur
and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker um the bill
uh regulates front lights headlights
usually aftermarket lights and also ride
sh lighting which is now becoming
popular uh the Senate amendment is
pretty simple They just added Provisions
or the provisions of this shall not
apply to a vehicle with original
equipment OEM front lighting or lighting
system of a similar type installed by
the Vehicle Manufacturer just a
clarification and believe it or not it's
Germaine too uh committee's good with it
concur the motion before us is to concur
on house Bill 1122 FN are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following en
titled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate ask
concurrence of the house house bill 1158
relative to establishing an exception to
vessel registration defining commercial
passenger vessel and regulating written
examinations and certifications for
W representative Walsh moves at we can
current is recognized to
speak yeah thank you Mr Speaker uh the
original bill is uh authorizing
municipalities to reduce speed limits
seasonally on congested roads uh the
Senate Amendment uh they simply didn't
like the way one sentence was written so
they changed highway system in a
municipality to Municipal highway system
that's all it does the committee is fine
with it we ask that you
concur the motion before us to concur on
House Bill 1158 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the I have it and the motion
is adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following en titled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
Senate as concurrence of the house house
bill 1550 authorizing municipalities to
representative Walt M was that we concur
is recognize as
speak yeah thank you Mr Speaker uh in
transportation we referred this is the
lemonade boat Bill uh allowing kids to
actually uh get around the commercial
vessel
registrations um the Senate
Amendment the Senate Amendment uh just
adds a little bit of clarification to
the examinations and testing for uh
commercial licenses uh for boats 34 ft
or over the passengers makees sense to
me committee's fine with it we ask that
you
concur motion before is to Cur on House
Bill 1550 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
iose nay the the eyes have it the motion
is adopted and CH recognize the cler for
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the passage of the
following titled bill with amendment in
the passage of which amendment the
Senate asked concurrence of the house
house Bill 1525 relative to credits for
the business profits tax and business
Enterprise
tax representative Jian move we concur
is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the credit carry forward is the amount
of money that a business is overpaid
when they pay their taxes and don't ask
for refund but use that money for future
tax payments in Prior years there was No
Limit and the amount that the state was
holding was getting larger and larger to
the point where we were concerned that
if suddenly the state asked for
everything uh not the state if if
businesses started asking for that money
back at too fast a pace it could cause a
serious problem uh right now that's been
uh brought down to 500% a business can't
have held more than 500% of their yearly
tax um amount owed and now current law
would drop this amount to 250 50%
January 1st 2025 that's a big change
that could come in the next 6 months so
the other body um Extended that time
four more years to give us time to see
how revenues are doing how the state is
doing and also giving us time to
potentially put a different bill in next
year or the year after um I would ask
that you press the green button to
concur
the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1525 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I nay no the eyes have
it the committee report is adopted and
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house in the pass of the
following ex titled bill with Amendment
the passage which amendment the Senate
as the concurrence of the house house
bill 1549 relative to buy in amount
deductions collected during the
chance representative Jin M that we
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker
the amend the changes to this bill would
um apply to uh Tournament game play uh
because of the fact that profit margins
are so small players have the option to
add a dealer add-in amount at their
option not required
of an amount not to exceed
$25 that would be a tip for the gaming
operator please press the green button
to concur thank you the motion before us
is to ur on House Bill 1549 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I oppose nay eyes have it
and the motion is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for further Senate
message thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs of the house and the
passage of the following titled bill
with Amendment the pass of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1613 is
establishing a trust fund for money from
Soil and Water environmental
settlements representa D moves that we
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you once again Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker uh money from Soil and Water
environmental contamination Court
settlements are subject to a 10%
disposition fee which would go to the
state um this fee with the changes of
the other body would be eliminated
um and so that the full amount from uh
the from a water contamination or soil
contamination settlement would go uh
completely to the mitigation of that
issue um the other other part of this
was the funds will lapse after two years
and go to other environmental uh
projects however the other body has
changed this to four years so there's
enough time to make sure that these
projects can get done I would urge the
the motion before us to concur on House
Bill 1613 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
iose nay eyes have it the motion is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the passage of the
following title bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment Senate as the
concurrence of the house house bill 1197
relative to criminal background checks
and relative to insurance coverage for
mination representative roads moves that
we non-c Concur and a seed to a
committee of
conference are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have
it and the house appoints representative
Roy
the motion you stated okay so the saidur
it should have said request committee
the motion that I stated was
correct it was a non-c Concur and
conference chair recogniz the clerk for
forther Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate conures of the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate as the concurrence
of the house house bill 1311 relative to
school district col ction development
policies representative lad moves that
we non-c Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker and yes we do
non-c concur on this and flush it down
the
toilet um the Senate version part two of
this bill uh is a new paragraph with
language regarding policies governing a
process for parent complaints regarding
literature media materials in one's
Library at
school we find that the language is
vague subjective and
inconsistent and the importance of this
is that it does require proper hearing
which has not had so uh this bill if it
were to pass with this in uh is
unacceptable uh there's terms such as in
one place uh you have to report within
30 days another place where it says
report within 30 calendar days it's
confusing CR CA needs to be spelled out
on how decisions are made so we ask that
you agree with our recommendation to
non-c concur this Bill thank
you the motion before us is to non-c
concur on House Bill 1311 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate as
the concurrence of the house house bill
476 relative to recount and audit
procedures in the Declaration of results
of a recount represent St
non Representative Steven Smith moves
that we non-c Concur and is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker this was
supposed to be a bill about re second
recounts when things go wrong as we know
from recent history they do and there
was controversy about whether they're
even allowed to do a second recount when
they knew there was a problem so what we
sent over was the fix for that part of
the bill establishes that there shall be
a second recount when a recount changes
the outcome of election guess what our
friends on the other side stripped
out that there is nothing left to talk
about there is no point to this bill I
will not waste my time in a committee of
conference and ask you to vote to non-c
concur the motion before us is nonc
Concur and House Bill 476 are you ready
for a question all those in favor to say
I iose nay the eyes have it motion is
adopted and the chair recognize the
clerk prer the Senate message for what
reason it member rise to make a motion
State your
motion um voting on the prevailing side
reconsidered okay
speak wish you do you wish to speak to
your
motion wait a minute yes please um thank
you Mr Speaker I wait a minute wait a
minute motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill
1197 member is ready to
speak many people in my section uh were
voting on a non-c Concur and we didn't
realize that it was a non-c concur with
Committee of conference so that's where
we're at right at this
point the motion before us is to
reconsider House Bill
1197 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
the motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill 1197 this is a division vote
you're in favor favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos or press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote 19 voting a 230 voting a the motion
pass chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following intitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate ask the concurrence
the house house bill 1596 re requiring a
disclosure of deceptive artificial
advertising Representative Steven Smith
moves that we concur chair recognized
representative
Brennan
wait thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker this bill is a
bipartisan Common Sense Bill requiring
the disclosure of the use of artificial
intelligence as it relates to
elections candidates and now election
officials this bill passed the house on
a Voice vote so strong that we didn't
even have to do a division vote for
clarification HB 1596 passed the other
we know the breakdown on the other side
of the wall so to pass something
unanimously is kind of a big
deal there's very minor change to this
bill made by the other
body it is done by the request of and
with the approval of the Secretary of
State this bill has enthusiastic support
from the Secretary of State and is a
high priority Bill the minor changes do
substantively I I'll keep it
brief and just urge the body to vote no
on the motion to nonc concur so that
another better motion may be made on
this Common Sense bipartisan bill that
allows voters to know if they are being
deceived and manipulated by artificial
intelligence technology thank
you chair recognize Representative
Steven
Smith thank you Mr
room not nearly
enough so here's what happened we send
the bill over to the Senate and they
made a language change and it was really
critical so let's say if somebody does a
deep fake you guys might be looking at
political ads or be serve them I don't
know just a guess and you go oh my God
look at this this information is
terrible I'm going to repost that you
know what you just did with your finger
with the language that we got back from
the Senate probably exposed yourself to
lawsuits penalties why should you be
liable you're not even the one that
created it
now why wouldn't I just go to a
committee of conference and argue my
case here's the real problem very smart
people who know about it and I do know a
few lawyers judges tech people they have
differing opinions on whether or not the
language actually does that I don't know
who I have to get in the room to figure
this out but I do not believe that I can
do it in the what six days that we have
left so we already passed some
this one I'm unwilling to vote for it
knowing whether or not for sure I am
putting regular people who have no clue
at risk just because their finger got
them sued so I'm not going to say what I
really want to say there I'm urging you
to support the non-c Concur and not put
those people at risk thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is to non-c
concur when House Bill thir
1596 this is going to be a division vote
the motion before us is
to non-c concur on House Bill 1596 it's
a division vote chair recognized
representative Lane for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that only those who
create the Deep fake are liable under
this bill and not those who use their
finger to post something on Facebook and
if I know that the SOS supports this
bill and it was the result of a barish
bipartisan effort and if I know that we
voted on this very same bill with varies
minor CH this same bill essentially
weeks ago then would I not then would I
vote against this motion to non-c concur
so that we can return and concur with
what the Senate has done to this vitally
important
Bill thank you chair recognized
Representative Steven Smith for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I knew
all that I'd agree but I don't and
that's the problem Mr Speaker if I know
that in the protections that were put in
the bill the Senate carved out the word
users that's you and your constituents
and Mr Speaker if I I have trepidation
about whether or not striking that out
puts them at risk then should I do
something smart instead of something
fast and press the green
button the motion before us is to non-c
concurent House Bill
1596 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're poos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
Shapiro
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 166 voting aay 184 voting nay the
motion
fails what reason member rise Mr Speaker
I move to non-concurrent former
committee conference on HB
1596 the motion is to non-c Concur and
form a committee of conference
on on House Bill
1596 representative tab requested a roll
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is non- Concur and
set up a committee of conference this is
a role call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will 10 to stay the
vote 182 voting a 168 voting a motion is
adopted
behalf of the
house chair appoints Representative
Steven Smith Jim
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate curs of the house in the passage
of the following titled bill with
amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence in the house cacr 13
relating to slavery and involuntary
servitude providing the slavery and
involuntary servitude shall be
prohibited in the state of New
Hampshire
non representative Moffett moves non-c
Concur and is recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker uh almost to
the finish line here so when CA cacr 13
came to state federal veterans several
months ago
seeking to enshrine an anti-slavery a
provision into our state constitution we
are all naturally interested in in fully
vetting this measure cacr 13's original
language sought to prohibit not only
slavery but also quote involuntary
servitude
unquote now our us Constitution's 13th
Amendment is as you all know should know
already abolished involuntary servitude
except
except as quote a punishment for a crime
whereof the party shall have been duly
convicted
unquote ca ca cacr 13's language would
do away with the 13th amendment's
involuntary servitude
language for New
Hampshire and this was problematical for
some folks uh so in that if we amend our
New Hampshire Constitution to preclude
the work mandates for the incarcerated
would would be opening a Pandora's box
of potential
lawsuits against the state on behalf of
incarcerated persons For Whom the state
might have certain work requirements as
part of Rehabilitation process processes
so our committee put things on hold
until we could communicate with the
commissioner of
Corrections who better than the
commissioner of Corrections to to to go
to on this we laid things out for the
commissioner and requested a response
she wrote back and stated that she was
okay with the language of cacr
13 that meant a lot so given that input
from the corrections commissioner our
committee proceeded to recommend uh to
pass regarding C cacr
13 the Full House this Full House did
also did likewise and the measure went
on to the other
body however during the other bod's
subsequent Eda
Edna hearings on cacr 13 there were
significant blowback lots of testimony
indicating serious concern again on how
the elimination of the prison work
requirement could be problematical
indeed uh this went back to our earlier
concerns that the corre corrections
commissioner addressed for us so again
the question was would this put our New
Hampshire Constitution at odds with our
Federal Constitution V Visa a v
involuntary
servitude now so the what the Senate
recommended was to Simply amend cacr 13
and have it emulate and use the exact
same language that's in the 13th amend
Amendment to the Federal Constitution so
initially that was something that I was
member but the measures sponsors and
stakehold olders made it very clear that
the Senate language was unacceptable to
them and a majority of our committee
members
agreed so instead of a concur
recommendation we considered we
considered a non-c concur with a request
for a committee of conference but
subsequent communication made it clear
that the other body was unlikely to
yield to any further compromised
language and the sponsors in
stakeholders also made it quite clear
that they were also unlikely to yield to
any language
changes so it was quite apparent that a
committee of conference would be likely
fruitless so this leaves us with this
recommendation to non-c concur with the
other bod's amending language which
would effective this would effectively
kill this measure for this term the ca
cacr supporters understand that they're
aware of this and we understand that
they very well may try again next term
with the language with which they are
committed to so all that said I would
encourage my colleagues to support our
non-c concur recommendation thank you Mr
Speaker the question is whether to non-c
concur on cacr 13 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those POs nay eyes have it and the
motion's adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate messages thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the Senate
refuses to concur with the house in the
adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill from sent up from
the house Senate Bill 249 establishing
magistrates in relative to release of
persons pending resolution of criminal
charges and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
the said committee Senators Carson Ganon
and
Susi representative rhs
speak thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker
uh this bill is the one of the many many
bail bills that we heard in our
committee and we have already asked for
a committee of conference for that
plethora of bail bills this particular
ular bail bill um has to do with
magistrates and the big old bill that we
sent over to the senate had magistrates
in there and they sent it back to us and
said no magistrates for you so then we
went and said look you got to do better
so they did they gave us three
magistrates so I don't really see the
point of going to another Committee of
conference and we already have one that
we're going to get this thing hammered
out so please let's just done with
it the question is whether the house
will refuse to exceed on Senate Bill 249
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos nay eyes
have it and the motion's adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house in the adoption
of the amendment to the following title
bill sent up from the house Senate Bill
460 establishing the crime of and
penalties for unlawful use of unmanned
aircraft system and requ requests a
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators
Chanley representative rhs moves at the
house refus to exceed and is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr
Speaker Senate Bill 460 came to us
and trying to regulate and make some
some changes around the drones and they
started with misdemeanor so it went
misdemeanor misdemeanor felony felony we
said that seems a little bit harsh
didn't change the underlining bill at
all left everything in there instead of
going from a misdemeanor or straight to
a misdemeanor straight to a felony we
said hey how about a violation and then
maybe a misdemeanor and then a felony
they said no that's too egregious so I
don't really see what we're going to
agree to so we're going to leave it
alone thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether the house will
refuse to exceed on Senate Bill 460 you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those BOS n eyes have
it and the motion is adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk for another of the
endless supply of Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house in the adoption of the
amendment of The Following titled bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 504
relative to Landing current use and
relative to magistrates bail
Commissioners the standards applicable
to and the administration of bail in
making Appropriations and request a
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators
Susi this will shock you but
representative RADS moves that the house
speak thank you Mr Speaker and we also
refuse to agree with the Senate um
Senate Bill 504 is the bill that we
started out with this morning and the
house voted to not concur not to
anything that bill is dead the other
bill that they decided attach to it came
out of Municipal and came out with an
itl recommendation that passed this
house so now I have two bills that
neither one passed the house so I don't
really imagine what magic trick we're
supposed to pull out of our hat at a
committee of conference but my
understanding the rules say we don't
want that bill so let's not go to a
committee conference on that
either the motion is that the house
refus to exceed to the Senate on Senate
Bill 504 you ready for the question a
division's been requested members take
okay the question is whether or whether
the house should refuse to exceed to the
Senate on Senate Bill 504 and this is a
division vote if you agree press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the vote 176 in
the affirmative 166 in negative the
Motions adopted the chair recognizes the
clerk prer the Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house in the adoption of the
following title bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 605 relative to
ethical standards for members of the
general court and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
said committee Senator Carson Bradley
and
Susie representative hell Hill moves
that the house refused to exceed and is
recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker um I
mentioned earlier there were two uh
bills that the legislative
Administration worked on for ethics and
recusal this this is the um bill from
the other side of the wall and uh we no
longer need it since we passed the
merged Bill earlier so I would request
you concur with this uh request to non
good all right the question is whether
the house refused to exceed on Senate
Bill 605 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos nay eyes have it and the Motions
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate refuses to concur with the
house in the adoption of the following
titled bill Senate from the house Senate
Bill 417 relative to out of home
placements for children and request a
committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators
representative Pearson moves that we
acceed to the committee of conference
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I all those oppose nay I
have it and the Motions adopted shair
recognizes the cler for fur need to read
oh I should read the
conferees the house appoints
Representatives Mark Pearson Jr Hull
Mary Jane walner and Patrick
[Music]
long Mr speaker the Senate refuses to
concur with the house in the adoption of
the amendment to the following title
bill Senate from the house Senate Bill
574 relative to the appointment of a
temporary agent for a minor child or Inc
incapacitated person and relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
Chanley representative Pearson moves
that we exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those posos nay eyes have it the
motion's adopted the house of points
representative Mark Pearson Lorie ball
Patrick long Candace gibons chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house and the
adoption of the amendment to the
following titled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 354 relative to
insurance cost sharing calculations and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators berzel Bradley and
Apprentice representative hunt moves
that we exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
Motions adopted and the house appoints
Representatives hunt Ammon burough and
spear chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill Senate from the
house Senate bill for 47 establishing a
ground ambulance cost reporting program
and a study by an independent Actuarial
and accounting expert of the cost of
providing ground ambul and services in
the state and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
said committee senators berzel avard and
Apprentice representative hunt moves
that the house exceed are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
all those oppose nay eyes have it the
motion's adopted and the house appoints
Representatives hunt burrow Spear and
Ammon the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following titled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 555 relative to the
receipt of pharmaceutical rebates by
insurers and Pharmacy benefits managers
and request a committee of conference
the president on the part of the Senate
has appointed as members of said
committee senators bsel avard and
pred representative hunt moves that we
exceed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I
all those POs nay eyes have it the
Motions adopted the house appoints
Representatives hunt burough Spear and
Ammon the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 266 relative to the
administration of school assessment and
accountability programs by the
Department of Education and requested
Committee of conference the president on
the part of the Senate has appointed as
members of said committee Senators Ward
Lang and Apprentice representative lad
representative lad moves that the house
exceed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I all those posos
nay eyes have it the motion's adopted
and the house appoints Representatives
lad cordelli Noble and luno the chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house in the adoption
of the amendment to the following
entitled bill sent it from the house
Senate Bill 340 relative to
communication between parents and school
districts regarding special education
special education reporting in
requirements and the officite of the
advocate for special education and
requested Committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said Committee
Apprentice representative lad moves at
the house exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay eyes have it the motion
is adopted the house appoints
Representatives lad cordelli Pell and
luno the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following titled bill sent up from the
house Senate Bill 379 relative to
emergency action plans for sports
related injuries and request a committee
of conference the president on the part
of the Senate has appointed as members
of said Committee of conference Senators
Lang gendro and
Apprentice representative lad moves at
the house exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I all
those posos nay eyes have it motions
adopted the house appoints
Representatives lad Cordell dry and
Damon chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate
messages pretty loud in here we're we're
close we're close just settle down and
let's get through it Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill Senate from the
house senate senate Bill 499 relative to
the supplemental nutrition assistance
program and the summer EBT program and
making Appropriations therefore relating
to providing disaster relief funding to
municipalities after a natural disaster
and requests a committee of conference
the president on the part of the Senate
has appointed his members of said
committee Senators bzel Bradley and
Whitley representative lad moves at the
house ex seed are you ready for the
question does somebody say division
please no okay
good all those in favor say I all those
all those oppos nay eyes have it the
motion's adopted the house appoints
Representatives Edwards walner and
cherski chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
and the adoption of the amendment to the
following en titled bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 521 relative to the
educational credentials for master
teacher and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed a members of
said committee Senators Ward Lang and
Apprentice
representative lad moves at the house ex
seed are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I all those oppose
nay guys have it the motion's adopted
the house appoints Representatives lad
cordelli McDonald and
cascaden chair recognizes the clerk
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house in the adoption
of the amendment to the following titled
bill Senate from the house Senate Bill
534 relative to campaign finance and
request a committee of conference the
president president on the part of the
Senate has appointed as members of said
Committee of conference Senators gray
Seuss representative quaale moves at the
house exceed are you ready for the
question a division's been requested
this will be a division vote members
the question is whether or not to exceed
to the committee conference on Senate
Bill 534 if you're in favor press the
green button oppos press the red why
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
represent
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity
to have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote
323 to 12 worth it
adopted the chair appoints
Representative Steven Smith Jim qua
Connie Lan and representative Mirad
there are five left it would be good if
we could quiet down because believe me
when I say I can make him take as long
as I want or go as fast as I can and
you Sher recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
in the adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled Bill senent up from
the house Senate Bill 371 relative to
the licensing and regulation of
Physicians and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
said Committee of conference Senators
Pearl gendro and
Fenton representative McGuire moves at
the house exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay
eyes have at the Motions adopted the
house appoints representative Simon
Steven Boyd J Smith and D
Shu
shair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate
messages and thank you thank you very Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house in the adoption of the
amendment to the following titled bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 480
relative to regulation of real estate
practice and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
said committee Senators Pearl gendro and
Perkins
quoka representative Carol Maguire moves
at the house exceed are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those pose nay eyes have it the
motion's adopted in the house appoints
Representatives groa Davis Tom Dolan and
Steve Brown the what Carol Brown chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house and the
adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 357 relative to
expanding the definition of providers
who can certify patients to the
therapeutic cannabis program and
requests a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said Committee
of conference Senators abbis Ganon and
Whitley representative Wayne McDonald
moves at the house ex seed are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those posos nay I have the
Motions adopted the house appoints at
Representatives Leon Nagel Weber and
Merchant chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate refuses to concur with the house
and the adoption of the amendment to the
following entitled Bill senent up from
the house Senate Bill 84 repealing
certain task forces study committees and
study commissions repealing the John G
wiet Memorial commission and making the
maintenance of the memorial a duty of
the joint legislative historical
committee and establishing a committee
to study the appeals process
administered by the Environmental
councils established under RSA 21- and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed his members of said committee
Senators gray Murphy and
Susi representative Hill moves at the
house exceed you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those POs
nay the eyes have it the Motions adopted
the house appoints Representatives
Vanessa shean Greg Hill Karen eel Janet
wall chair recognizes the clerk for one
more Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to
concur with the house and the adoption
of the amendment to the following en
titled bill Senate from the house Senate
Bill 513 relative to permitting charity
auctions by nonprofit corporations and
requested Committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said Committee
of conference Senators Lang inis and
Rosen
Wald represent Jan moves at the house
ACC seed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I all those posos
nay I as have it the Motions adopted the
house appoints representative spillsbury
Aly the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for a
motion to adjourn from the early
session resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet
the questions on a third reading motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppos nay the
eyes have it and the Motions
adopted uh house will be in order we
do the house will attend to an
announcement from the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker I understand that the there's
some excitement but we still have
legislative business in New Hampshire
ladies and
gentlemen if you were the first named
member of a committee of conference you
will be hearing from me by tomorrow at
the latest because it is your job to
confer with the first named senator for
scheduling Committees of Conference next
week please if you have not been in
touch with that corresponding senator
look to the bill dockets they are being
updated as we speak additionally uh if
you have if you have left paper work in
your C Pockets please take it out with
you the next time we are in session on
the 13th your Committee of conference
packets will be in your seat in your
seat boxes lastly on June 13th our last
session day we will be celebrating sear
sucker day so please feel free to wear
ladies and gentlemen we still have
requests for unanimous consent and we
motion
okay representative Nagel is recognized
representative Nagel waves off
representative canons recognized for
unanimous
consent
sex I've always wanted to do that now
attention for the past 25 years I
haven't
had I haven't had
sex I haven't had an intense desire to
have sex this is due in part to my lack
of testosterone the same is true for
most of my uh fellow transgender women
that I know so in theory um that the
transgender woman women um maybe uh
sexual predators is
false in 2009 I was asked by
representative Ed Butler from Hart's
Landing to speak to a house committee on
what it means to be a transgender person
in New
Hampshire at that time most of the
transgender people I knew were very
private and hidden from public
view we had about 20 to 30 people
transgender people and and individuals
speak out out during that first
transgender rights hearings in the House
and Senate committee
meetings that bill that year passed by
one vote in the house when speaker Terry
nelli stepped off the podium and cast
her vote ultimately that bill was
defeated in the
Senate but before I left the state house
that
day I was asked by two reps if I
let's keep in mind that back then it was
around 2008 2009 and my carpentry
business just died due to the banking
crash also my bank was about to
foreclose on my home and these reps were
asking me if I wanted to take a job for
$100 a year yeah right
instead I learned how to drive big rigs
and drove Long Haul for 5 years driving
over 550,000
miles during that time I thought a lot
about the idea of running for
office after driving for five years I
settled in the city of summersworth I
was going to say town of summersworth
but Dana Hillyard would have my
butt um
the f I ran for um summer worth School
Board shortly after moving in and I
won I got to learn a lot about the city
and the community the following year
this transgender person ran for uh state
house and I
won I didn't realize at the time but I
was one of four transgender elected
States that year I went from being a
hidden person to a very National figure
representing my New Hampshire Community
as well as the transgender people and
their families across the
country over the F past six years I have
fought for equality health care and
protections for us
all while sitting on the health and
human services and elderly Affairs
committee I believe that my effort with
the support of house members and our
communities have resulted in New
Hampshire being a safer and healthy
place for all people including a
transgender people their families and
friends and it's a great place for us to
live with at peace with one
another I know that some of you don't
understand why I am the way that I am
I it's not something I decided to be
but it is who I
am I've just had to learn to
live my life true to myself and to live
with you as
well I will not be running for another
term in the
legislature I can hear some of you
that during my six years as a rep I've
made many friends on both sides of the
and our private
discussions but you haven't gotten rid
of me yet I'll be back to share my voice
as a private citizen and Community
leader in the years to
come thank you all for your service to
our state it has been my pleasure to
[Applause]
for what reason does a member R Mr Mr
Speaker I move to print the remarks of
the previous speaker in the permanent
representative Osborne moves at the
house stand in recess for the purposes
of the introduction of bills and rooll
Bill amendments and rooll Bill reports
and receiving messages you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those pose nay eyes have it the motion's
adopted the house is in recess until